this is Jocko podcast number 111 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening so almost two
years ago I had a guy on the podcast by
the name of Jo Dee medic and we ended up
talking for so long that we actually
turned one podcast into two podcasts the
first one was a review of his book which
had just come out it was called
unflinching the making of a Canadian
sniper and then we did a second podcast
right after that that was just us
talking and discussing some more of the
details of where his life had gone since
that book had come out and those
podcasts are number 24 and number 25 and
if you haven't listened to those yet
just stop here go back and listen to
them first and in those podcasts we
discussed Jody's early life and how he
ended up in the military and his sniper
training and his two deployments to
Afghanistan and the events of January
11th 2007 when during an operation he
hit a landmine and lost both of his legs
below the knee and from there he
struggled to stay alive but he did and
he made it back to Canada where he then
struggled to recover from his injuries
and then he struggled to adapt to his
new life and along the way he struggled
to overcome addiction to pain
medications that had been given to him
so freely but he did overcome those
struggles and made a new life and wrote
a book and got elected as a member of
the City Council of the City of Ottawa
and he continued to raise his young
girls and take care of them and
by all accounts we're talking about a
model citizen in fact I'd go so far as
to say a model human being but things
aren't always as they appear
and although Jody looked to be doing
great by any measure behind that public
persona the struggle continued and I saw
a glimpse of it when Jody came down to
be on the podcast I first noticed it
when I made reservations for Jody at a
hotel by my house and I just got a nice
little hotel nearby me so I could pick
him up easy and didn't think much of it
I gave him the hotel information then a
couple days later he called me up and
said he needed to transfer to a
different hotel because the hotel that I
had made reservations at didn't have
handicap accessible rooms of course I
felt like a like a jerk but at the same
time I didn't really understand because
I'd seen all these video clips of Jody
walking around and and actually running
around and he'd gotten second place in
this TV show called The Amazing Race
where he's doing all these different
challenges and I saw pictures of him and
videos of him running and driving cars
and even riding motorcycles driving
motorcycles so clearly there was
something that I didn't understand that
was going on and maybe he wasn't as
mobile as I thought he was and when I
went to pick him up at the airport I
wasn't really sure what to expect I
didn't know if he's gonna be in a
wheelchair I didn't know if he's gonna
need help getting around and as I drove
through the pickup area looking for him
he wasn't hard to spot he was standing
at the curb big beasts over six feet
tall and he walked over the car with
confidence when it was really zero
indication that he was walking on two
prosthetic legs and you know so we
recorded the podcast after
afternoon and it took forever was like
five hours or six hours and then we got
done with that we went grab steak and
the next day you know he said hey can
you give me a tour San Diego can you
show me you know some of the sights
around here and so we did that and I
took him down to the the buds compound
where the seal training is and then I
took him to the SEAL Teams and we went
to the USS Midway the aircraft carrier
museum and we were walking all over that
and and then he wanted to go down to the
beach town where I live in so we walked
around there and it was awesome and he
was enjoying it being down from the cold
frozen tundra of Canada and as we got
towards the end of the day you know Jody
started walking a little bit slower and
and I noticed on his face he had a look
of discomfort right that he was you
could see he was trying not to really
reveal it but it was there and then
finally said he you know can we sit down
for a minute these things start to hurt
after a while and he's pointing down at
his legs and said of course yeah no
problem man so we sat down for a little
while and he recovered a little bit and
then we got up and we walked a little
bit more and then he said hey man can we
sit down again and I said yeah man of
course so then we sat down for a little
while and then when he got up again he
said hey can we just head back to your
house and maybe sit or sit around there
for a little while these things are
they're starting hurt pretty good right
now
you know the skin wears off it starts to
bleed and you know it doesn't feel good
man and I said yeah brother no problem
so we headed back to my house and and we
went up on the deck and we sat there and
just kind of hung out talked and and it
became clear to me something that I did
know from my other friends that have
been wounded badly that it's a lot
harder than it looks it isn't the bionic
man and it's hard to adapt the
intermingling of human flesh with
mechanical parts is not a natural thing
it's not a smooth thing it's a battle
and it's a battle
that's hard for us to perceive from the
outside but it's a battle that takes
place every minute of every day usually
behind the scenes privately because as
soldiers as Marines these men learn to
suffer and bear their burdens silently
and without complaints and it was here
at my house that Jody explained to me
why he needed a handicapped accessible
room he said yeah you know Manik I get
home and I got to take my legs off and
then I gotta crawl to the bathroom to
use the toilet and I gotta crawl to get
in the shower and I need those little
handles to pull myself up be it's a
struggle and Jody suffered and struggled
again not outwardly not in public
but alone he pressed on and we kept in
touch over the last couple years you
know text messages and what's going on
and did you see this and I sent you that
and I watched as Jody continued on his
journey of his life and he has awesome
to watch and he got back to Canada and
he started to podcast and he continued
with his political career and he wrote
another best-selling book called
everyday heroes and you know from a
distance everything appeared to be going
great but again things aren't always
what they seem and behind all that Jody
was struggling and a couple months ago I
got a text a simple text from Jody and
it read bro
the enemy outflanked me now in military
terms that's about as bad as it gets it
means the enemy has attacked your
weakness it means the enemy has the
upper hand it means you have lost
momentum in the battle and it means you
could very likely be overrun that being
overrun means that you're gonna get
killed
and I could see from that text that
Jodie was at war again not on the
battlefield but in his life but Jodi's a
soldier and duty fought back because
that's what soldiers do then a little
while later he sent another text that
read I'm finally turning into the ambush
and starting to fight through he
attacked the problems he's back on track
again back on the path and came down to
visit me and after talking to him a
little bit and discussing what he's been
through I asked him if he would come on
and talk about it so other people not
not just veterans but everyone that
struggles all of us can learn from what
he's been through and what he's overcome
so here we are once again and with that
Duty Jacko welcome back to the podcast
wow you had me and we know get in the
fields there for a minute
thank you yeah man it's um thank you for
that you work you were talking to me
last night about about the texts that
you'd sent me yeah
and you said you know there was some
there were some heavy texts I sent you
and and I was like really and you said
yeah and I go did I pick up on it and
you were like yeah yeah yeah and I
thought you did well no when I read
through them I clearly did
yeah and just do the responses and the
conversation we were having but that
that first text that you sent I was like
damn and and then I of course I went and
went back on your social media looked at
what you've been going through you
dropped off social media and so you had
basically reached out and said you know
hey brother needs to lead a little air
support over on this side and so what
happened from I mean just you leave here
from from the last podcast two years ago
you go back to Canada yeah you start
your podcast that was going great yeah
great podcast oh yeah got a you know a
lot of people are listening to it
getting a lot of feedback from people a
lot of people hit me like a Jody's
podcast is great so you're doing that
and you're working on the other book
that just came winning that book come
out October last October
last October hits the shelves bestseller
running boom yeah so when I was already
I was already I hadn't done a podcast
since me actually last podcast I did was
with some guys from Kansas off that
started their own company tak goo beaver
that was like supposed to springboard us
into the next podcast we had some other
guys coming in some other kin soft
entrepreneurs and we were starting to
like kind of shift to supporting
veterans in their business opportunity
because it seems like we're all becoming
entrepreneurs or the guys that will
employ our friends and things of that
and that's what I want to focus on is
how do we help the troops after they go
through what I went through because I
had zero plan nobody had really dealt
with this stuff in Canada since Korea
really we had some guys in Bosnian that
but the the chain of command and them
and the government frankly lied about
the fact that Canadian forces were in
combat in the former Yugoslavia that all
aside the point is we were we were
trying to lead by I was trying to lead
by example Luke my my echo Luke
as I was trying to help out and he was
doing his best and he was seeing the
wheels fall off the Jody medic machine
and he kept trying to like put him back
on and gun taped them and just do his
best though because him and I it's not
like we're like close buds like we're
not like besties since we were kids or
anything so he's trying to keep his
distance and keep that like Jody medic
podcast is Jody medics and I'm I'm Luke
I could tell too and I kept telling my
friends that you know that we're close
as well like I can tell he really wants
to help but he's not sure and then one
day so I had a kind of a perfect storm
so I moved out of my house in October
last October 16 and you know I'll just
get that out of the way that was the
beginning really of things going south
and it's not because my ex and I are
enemies by any stretch we're still
friends we have two amazing kids we had
amazing life it's just sometimes you
know sometimes these units don't mesh
right and that's just kind of the way it
went you know we both have different
visions of our future and and things
like that so but then you kind of gotta
put on the the face for the public you
know and so I stopped going to the gym
at that time I stopped seeing my
therapist just because he's on the other
end of town and I can't be bothered
right now I got too many other things to
do and even when I was here like you
said you saw I forgot about that walk
and you're right I remember sitting on
the wall it is it is at Ocean Beach obe
oh and I love like of the Americana
that's what we call in kenmare canna
history is amazing to me in the
California beach each Beach has its own
history and the group I look and you're
talking about and I'm looking around at
all these buildings built in the 40s 50s
60s and I'm and in my mind I drove route
66 to get here like I love the history
of this of this country so much and then
I was on route 66 until I saw the Pony
Express trail is to your left and I went
okay turned left and I followed the Pony
Express trail down into Arizona
but even then
like you said like the pain was really
hitting me and I'm terrified of the
pills because of becoming addicted and
so okay what do you do for pain if
you're not taking pills
and I'm not a weed guy like I know I
talked about it know everything but I
don't know anything about it but I know
a lot about Crown Royal I'm in Jack
Daniels and and Captain Morgan and I are
good buddies and so I found when I went
from having a beer after work or in my
case I like cider I know I get made fun
of for her but booze is booze boys you
know I'm saying I can't wait to have
that cider after work or that that rum
and coke when I get to the get to the
pub with the with the guys you guys now
the guys that you're talking about now
are your fellow people you're working
with in the government a lot of them are
politicians but also just some of the
boys that because Ottawa is like the
biggest military posting in Canada okay
but also all the cans suffer in that
area God so I got you know buddies that
are coming back from deployment in Iraq
on and off and they come in for their
home for months I've gone for three home
for three gone for a months like so
whenever you're you gonna hear from them
you run out and of course they just got
back from the sandbox so they want to
have a beer or two and you know and I'm
like okay because it might like I'm
going going going I get up at six put on
my suit go to work come home and I'm in
pain the whole time and from the pain
you saw to October 2016 and then it
comes spring 2017 now it's just it's
reached points where I wouldn't but I
was thinking about drinking before work
mm-hmm
and it's not because I'm like stressed
out and I was stressed out but it's more
like oh man like my because I there is a
deadening of the of the vein for sure
and it's like well uber ride is only 12
bucks to get to work and this and that
or my staff drives right by my place to
go so I could have her pick me up and
that discipline kept me from doing that
for awhile and then I had a trip to
Oregon to go shooting at the Leopold
shooting Academy they opened there that
was great
but before I left I think I took my legs
off for a solid three to four weeks and
as in my wheelchair and that kind of
sucked because my car isn't set up to
drive you know my place I got which is
like a block from the house so it's not
that far from the kids and the ex and
everything so you know I'm seeing them a
lot anyway and stuff but nothing else in
my life is set up to live without legs
even like where I keep my coffee in the
kitchen is for when I'm on my legs so
I'm in my I'm in my wheelchair the first
day and I'm like I don't really make
coffee when I'm in my wheelchair do i oh
Tong's right so I get tongs out of the
cupboard reach off I can do this
whatever adapt and that's like okay time
to go to work
oh shoot and then I did call my staff
and she picked me up I already took an
uber but then I went to Oregon and that
was a week like it was about seven eight
nine nine days on my legs straight
excruciating pain the whole time well
whatever was happening the doctor I
finally went back and she said that like
my skin had reached a point where it
couldn't regenerate fast enough so it
was just breaking down and then the way
I like to wear my legs was being
rejected by the body so I like to wear
with it gets called a suction suction
hold so it's like a vacuum until you
release it with a with a valve and my
body was like well we're done with this
but I'm like no me no like leg leg
sleeve leg sleeves take away mobility
you know wants and so my you know that
if you're gonna be dumb you better be
tough everything comes that you gotta be
tough yeah and you know and and and and
I didn't have and I'm not living with
with a medic anymore right so she's not
there to be like hey stupid put yourself
like take the legs off and let someone
take care of you my mom actually moved
to Ottawa December 16 and I'm completely
ignoring her advice because you know
what mom mom's always gonna try and look
after you but come on mom I'm 40 years
old Jesus and I was pushing away against
a lot of the same same things I but then
in the same day would tell people like
hey man you gotta let people look after
you you know cuz I get texts I probably
same as you right I get texts
pm's I get DMS on Instagram and Twitter
and Facebook on my fanpage and then the
podcast page hey what's going on like I
need help with this and I'd be like
don't be afraid to go get help don't be
afraid to reach out those around you
love you let them look after and I'm
completely ignoring any of this advice
myself cuz I'm like I kicked oxycotin
when I was 22 I think and on deployment
I stopped smoking just cuz I wanted to I
drink on the weekend I don't need to
drink but Neiman while I'm sitting there
checking these messages while having a
drink I know and I look back and like
I'm so stupid but it I guess sometimes
you got to go through there's a reason
why you go back to basics is there like
in your mind when you're going through
that are you thinking to yourself I
could stop if I want it I don't want to
yeah I don't it's not getting in the way
of anything I'm still functional I'm
still at work I'm still doing to me my
main job was what I was elected to do
right I have a four year in my mind it's
a it's kind of like being in the army
where you're on for your four-year
commitment right so I'm like well right
now I have a four-year commitment I'm
not drinking at work I mean at some
point I did start drinking at work but
in politics and business as you know
like sometimes after lunch instead of
going back to the office you have a beer
and you're still working mm-hmm you're
still talking about issues you're still
getting like I used to get a lot of
advice from I shouldn't say used to I
said I get a lot of advice from the
other more experienced politicians
because that's what you do and we all
would have a beer or a cider and then
they'd go back to the office and I'd
stay and keep on the phone and yeah I'll
have one more you know and then another
group of guys would come in from like oh
hey yeah you're still here like you know
so-and-so is already back at City Hall
what kind of what kind of drunk are you
happy I'm a happy-go-lucky I get a
little loud but it's not like I'm like
hey what's going on about it but you
know anyway well I know it's your no no
I'm actually just asking to eat I think
you could you could still call on the
phone and be like hey buddy bubble you
know
people when they drink they get angry
some people and they drink they slur
their speech really bad and so you got
all these different types of you know
dreams when I drink I basically just
like em more of tako ya-ya-ya I'm more
Jody yeah for the most part I do slurp
but even I could not be like a blur my
words okay well I'll drink some water
for a minute and then I'll get it back
or I'll have a coffee and I'm good I'm
no I'm normal and even when I'm like I
rarely get fall over drunk and right if
ever but let me rewind I know that's a
long answer to a short question but so
may I get back from Oregon and I'm just
like dying and then I had to go real
quick down to Albany cuz of part of my
job with the city is I'm the sports
commissioner and I'm desperately trying
to get the CrossFit Games to bring the
eastern regional games to Ottawa because
I just think that'd be awesome to have
an Ottawa we you know we got the UFC in
Ottawa I was a part of that it so I was
really proud and I said when I got the
job I said I want to do two things in
the four years at the UFC and get a
CrossFit Games so I'm still trying to do
the CrossFit Games I got less than a
year to do it but I think we can do it
but anyway there's a lot of people that
participate in CrossFit that listen to
this podcast yeah I've met a lot of them
and you know what the CrossFit guys are
crafty and Albanese City itself they
don't want to lose the CrossFit Games so
they knew I was in town and they started
sweetening the deal if you know what I
mean and the CrossFit Games go well otto
was offering us this al but he would you
got hey it's business I get it but you
know what I'm coming back I got back
from that trip that was about a four-day
trip from Ottawa to Albany and back and
when I was here with you guys I didn't
bring a wheelchair because that's what I
meant by I crawl around which is why I
could stay at your house but I don't
want your kids seeing a grown man
crawled to the bathroom and it's not
because I'm above crawling it's just
it's one of those personal things in my
own space I'm not above it and around
like loved ones okay so that's why you
want your own space and even and stuff
like that so even when I visit my dad I
get a hotel room you know my dad loves
me and I'm not but it's also my space or
if I want to crawl around naked I can
right and so anyway that's why that so
then I get back and I'm take the legs
off and I just I can't put them back on
I look I would like I don't know if I
said it on your show last time but I
have mornings where I look at my
prosthetics I'm like [__] sorry sorry
for sorry I know we're allowed but I'm
trying to be a little bit bit of a man
deco you know what I mean
I mean echo I don't want you having to
edit out things I say I took him off and
I just looked I just threw him across
the room I said I can't deal I have a
wound in my left stump
did I show it to you no it's been there
since April of 14 and it happened I
remember the second it happened my
brother and I were doing an amazing race
thing post show in Alberta and we did a
little like you know go hey Jody and
Corey from mazing grace we we got a few
bucks for it we gave a speech to some
kind of convention and then I was
walking down the airport to to the plane
and I felt something go on my foot it's
and it's like having a hot spot when
you're on a run large or whatever except
I can't really shift what part of my
foot and walking on I just can't and it
went from a little tiny like breaking
the skin to something the size in Canada
we have two knees it's two dollars I
know you guys still use dollars a piece
I got a 50-cent piece and then back now
it's down to like a pinprick of scab but
that's what are we talking now we're uh
almost four years right and I had to
mitigate that the whole time and it was
painful and I got a couple in I got two
infections in the four years from it but
that's where I was like that's it
I need to let my self heal I need to
like let my body regenerate except now
from that and it took me until fall late
fall to realize that when I did that I
might as well have stepped on another
landmine and I went through it took me
to late fall to go because I was like
because that's when things really went
south because you basically not even
basically because you
lost your legs again yeah I lost my legs
again except because truly when you were
down here even though you were in pain
bro we were doing you know we were
walking up and down stairs we were we're
doing whatever we walked all over that
aircraft all over that aircraft carrier
up and down stairs we walked all over
the seal compound walked or you know we
I loved it I went out on the beach when
we walked out in the future you guys
torture the the recruit yes in every
step I was like because they got a dig
through the sand yeah but to me that's
hallowed ground bourlingueur when you
took me to the grinder I remember stand
there like this is the grinder like I'm
okay I'm Canadian Army and but there's
some things where you go you just you
feel right if I brought you up to the
recruit spot and for basic in the
Canadian Army you'd be you'd feel you
get that feeling this is where soldiers
are born yeah it says don't say there's
been a lot of those little they have the
little fins on the grinder so what what
Jody's talking about is where they
trained seals that first day in the
movies right yeah it's and they have
little fins so like little dive fins
there's little for you know the Marine
Corps they have boots yeah yeah in the
Army they have boots hanging on the
ground they paint them on the ground
well in the atma grinder at Budds they
have little swim fins too little tiny
swim fins are pain and there's you know
a couple hundred of them and that's when
you get out there for PT you stand on
your little set of swim in and then as
the days go by there's less and less
yeah yeah right and then and I've read a
I've read if I've read less than 24 Navy
SEAL books from from the beginning to
today right yours included I'd be
surprised I've read I've read the the
old lips right everybody eyes I've read
about the original Rangers I've read
about the Canadian American Special
Service Force actually when I was with
Rob my buddy from the Green Berets down
in Yuma I was wearing a ranger up
t-shirt that's like a Special Service
Force tribute you know to me like that's
our history that's the history of soft
in Canada and the US and and and then
you know and buds in the Green Beret or
Navy SEALs in the Green Berets were kind
of created by Canada at the same sea
look at me I'm a [__] nerd when it
comes to this stuff so do me you know
the I haven't been there but I've heard
about it because a lot of my friends
have been there the
aziz they have a parade ground like in
the middle of their compound have you
been there no I've never been to
Australia they're the the only time they
use this parade ground apparently is at
memorial services for their men yet and
I believe that no one walks on it it's
just in the middle of their compound no
one walks well in Canada we have a
similar thing where if you're on the
parade Square and it's not parade like
you're going on extra duty like if the
sergeant major catches you on his parade
square hey you better be have a brew in
your hand or you better be on parade and
if you're not like because it's usually
like oh my go from here to there it's
right across the parade square but it's
a short route yeah and it's like one of
those tests right then the new guys in
the hallways of most units the unit
emblem is in the floor and and there's
one of those sergeants that just has
nothing better to do but to stand there
and watch and see who steps on and even
if you're like family of one of the
troops you get the knife and it's
awesome but when I was here I wasn't
gonna not go see the grinder because my
[__] legs hurt don't be a [__] and
I'll be honest that first night after
you dropped me off I had a couple drinks
to ease the ease the day like when we
left your porch and you drop me back at
the hotel yeah I I went I had a few
drinks the hotel bar you know and I and
I I was actually toying with talking to
you about this stuff magnin because it
was bugging me then and I'm like okay
what do I do
do I talk to tacos the kind of guy
Echo's is the kind of energy you want to
be around and like you know and that's
one of this part of this this trip for
the last 10 days I've been on is it's
kind of like refining so a lot of my
Canadian and American friends that have
kept me on on the straight and narrow
mm-hmm or is that much as you can do it
for Jody medic and call bro it's a
constant wrestling match right that
little evil and the good angel except a
lot of times they high-five each other
okay let's see what happens and yeah man
so when the lights came off so no car so
now my mommy
uber or my staff or my ex are driving me
around all happy to do it
all not like holding it against me but
at the same time
man I am out of sandwich meat hmm okay
now I need to go to the store hey mommy
can can you drive my car and take me to
the store and and then that's I kind of
turned my hat backwards and kind of like
you know tried to like you know cowboy
up and do it but I took me again till
then my daughter turned 9 September 19th
I think it was her I missed a lot of her
birthday from being hungover and she was
at this awesome trampoline place and I'm
in a wheelchair
and I remember getting there and being
like all I want to do right now is jump
on trampolines with my with my little
girl and I can't a and B I'm an hour and
a half late for her party because I
decided to have too many drinks last
night and that was when I was like what
the [__] is really wrong with me because
I couldn't really get it and then what
is what is the escalation right so you
were down here with me yeah you know we
worked hard we because it is you know
doing a podcast like when we do sit
there and talk to each other about
intense stuff for five hours yeah then
we went eight we stayed up late we get
up early the next day we go do all the
stuff that we did yeah and you get done
you have a couple drinks right what does
that escalation look like over time
where you're like you know what you're
not even saying like oh I don't know if
I stab drinks you're like hey
as soon as Jocko gets in his car I'm
getting some drinks right now yeah
something that you recognized is it
something that you just you just said to
yourself you know what this gonna make
me feel better right now and I gotta go
Goggin I don't remember exactly what
months I was here do you like I don't
remember no I know it was a warm month
and ah in Canada like it was cool but it
was spring or fall well we started in
December it was 24 podcasts in that's
how many December of what 2015 so it
must have been spring for 16 yes spring
16 so I could I remember in Canada
wasn't cold but like we were wearing
still wearing down vests with with
hoodies and stuff when I was doing my
quick podcast for I left so at that time
I was it was this the pain was just kind
of like give a couple drinks for bed
but even that was bugging me and that's
what I mean like when I was but then
like if it had been this spring where
we'd met yeah I would have been like
like this the whole time and like as
soon as Jacko's gone I mind it's just
like last night when we had dinner I
might've just been like forget I'm
having drinks I don't care if jock was
here because being around someone like
you like I used to be the guy who could
I don't need to drink I'd go months and
be like oh yeah I'm gonna drink like you
know I love a drink and and you don't
drink and you haven't drank since you
were like in your 20s I think no no I
haven't drank since I retired oh okay
last time I felt the effects of alcohol
which i felt quite strongly was
basically the day I retired yeah yeah
that you had retired which was October
1st 2010 you know of course me and the
boys we went out we had a bunch of
drinks I woke up in the morning because
I still wake up early and I woke up in
the morning I was like well yeah that's
done because I got other stuff I got to
do now and basically when I no longer
had we'll call them friends to drink
with yeah then I was like yeah well I'm
done with that and I just ever since
then just haven't really you know I've
had and another thing is sometimes
people think I'm like offended if they
have drinks or whatever I mean I'm not
you know I remember actually I went I
was on the first podcast I was on was
Tim Ferriss and we got done with the
podcast and he you know we went out to
go grab some food because I was staying
the night at his house and we went out
and we got some food we got some mistake
and he's like do you mind if I have a
glass of wine with this I was like yeah
you know a reformed alcoholic just
decided one day you like my dad one day
he was like yeah this gets in the way of
work yeah that's kinda that's kind of my
attitude isn't really yeah yeah and if I
want to drink something that tastes good
then I'll drink chocolate milk I love
the taste of chocolate yeah right I mean
that stuff makes me feel good yeah and I
just yeah and people asked me about a
lot of and I need it's something that I
need to address on the podcast cuz the
other thing is just I might as well
Dublin is a little bit right at this
moment when I was a kid I was in the
hardcore music yeah I was into and and
the type of music that I listened to was
against
drinking and against think it was yeah
pun that the yeah we're talking straight
edge we're talking minor threat where
yeah really
yes absolutely and so it was almost and
I was again I was never really I'm very
I'm very I'm not a real good follower so
anytime there's some kind of a movement
going on I'm always like saying wait why
is this movement going why am I always
questioned I can't just jump in I'm hard
to get on board with something like that
so it was around I wasn't like so
there's a there's a thing with
straightedge okay so this this thing was
called straightedge it started in I'd
say Utes the the epicenter of it was in
Washington DC
the first band really to coin the term
was Minor Threat which is a punk band
Harvard I assume they were partiers no
not at all by the name no and so one of
the things that one of the symbols of
straightedge was he only to go to a bar
or when kids used to go to bars for a
show for a for a music show if they were
too young to drink once that when the
bouncer looked at their ID card if
they'd put a big X on their hands and so
the straightedge symbol was they put the
X's on their hands meaning look I don't
drink and it's actually funny cuz I took
my to my kids to see the white buffalo
the other night in San Diego and it was
awesome and but when they came when they
showed their IDs they got the X's on
their hands and I was like yeah so what
the straightedge kids would do is they
would draw big X's on their hands
meaning hey look I'm not drinking so
there was that an in that of course
morphed into like a gang and there was
you know by the time I was a you know
middle teenager there was hardcore gangs
that would assault people that drank and
would get crazy while I was amazing
together with the Juggalos yeah so it's
just so what so some when I was a kid I
was okay and I wasn't like a full-on I
wasn't drawing AK I don't think I know I
never like had X's and O's Reagan but I
but I understood philosophically what
was being said which was look
I want to win right I'm hardcore I want
to be stronger I want to be aware and I
want to be alert and drinking and doing
drugs doesn't give me any other things
so at that that's so sorry but even at
that age
do you understood the fuel that goes
into the Machine affects the performance
yes see I didn't get that as a Youngman
yes so here I am and and it was you know
I wasn't disciplined and you know I had
a before the seals oh yeah I had a band
a hardcore band the name of my hardcore
band was rage of discipline that was the
name of a hardcore band that was after
that's what that's what Bronson's
Children is my first band when I was
like 13 was called Bronson's children
but then as I got older I got more
hardcore then it became a rage of
discipline there was also about
knowledge Bronson his children Bronson
Rogers Charles oh he didn't drink I
don't even know
Oh beautiful name we do know Charles
Bronson was a badass when I was a kid I
thought Charles Bronson was the man
because he's the baddest man on the
planet yeah he was you know a tail
gunner in a you know bomber in World War
two and he grew up in the mines yeah
when he was a kid when he's 10 years
older 11 years old he was working in the
mines oh yeah and until he was old
enough he used to have to wear a dress
cuz he didn't have his parents didn't
have money to buy him clothes he had to
wear one of his sister's dresses down to
the mines so then he went to World War
two and then he became and you know you
he's just had great movies he always
played this stoic character that was
unemotional and so I was you know hey
when I grew up on to be Charles Bronson
of course so then we had a band it was
called Bronson children well as we got
more hardcore eventually that name
morphed into rage of discipline of which
Elgin James was the guitarist who's
another buddy of mine that echoes met
who will come on the podcast at some
point and tell his crazy life story
which I'm a big part of in the beginning
until I return we got the years of the
pre military Jocko series yeah yeah yeah
so I'll be tuning into that one long
story then I joined the military yeah so
when I joined the military what do I
want to be I want to be I want to be a
seal I want to be a frogman
I want to be the best frogmen I can be I
show up at a SEAL team guess what
frogmen do frogmen drink okay cool I
didn't know that now that I know that
give me a give his shot of Jagermeister
because
and that was sort of how you proved
yourself and that's what we did and I
was immature and dumb and and despite
everything I just said about like hey
I'm a little bit I'm hesitant to really
follow well now I'm in the SEAL Teams
this is my dream job
and this is what I want to do if you
don't buy in you're not in yeah it's
like it's not I don't even know if it's
just like that's the way it is yeah when
I first drink I was 17 right after I
finished basic training I show up at the
regiment and they're like all right what
are you drinking
and I'm like because my family's full
alcoholics on both sides
there's nothing thought that I guessed
I'm like you know grandpa was my other
grandpa was and grandpa's grandpa was
and you know one of my uncle nothing
okay they might hear this but we all
know what you do okay right so not a big
deal but and Dad but dad was one of
those guys he was like well that just
doesn't affect me and me personally like
you as a kid I'm like I don't really see
the interest like what I can throw up on
myself and whatever whatever and I was
one of those kids that say no to drugs
actually worked on mmm you know like now
I'm older I'm like man I should've been
smoking weed since I was like 12 and
[__] but I still don't but I did I just
like you see the effects on people like
when I was a bouncer I'm like yeah the
guy who smoked weed were really mellow
yeah when the guy did coke and drank
like they were the one through the
problem but when I get to the regiment
the first night of parade is done and
they're like hey what are you drinking
I'm like well I'm 17 I'm like this is an
army mess like it's okay just don't
worry we're all gonna keep it like it
your loves like I'm not trying to tell
the world like hey underage people drink
but hey underage people drink but it's
an environment full of people that are
there to look out for each other anyway
so I had a couple of drinks and I'm like
okay this is the way it is and same
thing yeah work Monday to Friday you
work your ass off you go hard as you can
like you go hard in the paint right your
your tires are stripped at the end of
the day Friday rolls around okay we
don't see it 8:00 a.m. Monday morning
boys and you know if you're gonna drink
don't drive but if you do drink driver
that's what you got told when you when
you're dismissed for the weekend right
yeah and so basically how to fun blow
off the steam don't hurt anybody and
take care of each other's basically what
you're told
so the SEAL Teams definitely is a
culture it was even more when I first
got in because now you're talking about
the old Vietnam guys and it wasn't a war
going on and it was just hey what are
you gonna do if there's no war going on
and you're you're a frogman what are you
gonna do well we drank and and I'm not
I'm gonna look down on I mean we had a
great time it was fun mom did we you
know it was it was fun it was what you
you know was what we did and I'm not
even trying to say anything negative
about it but that's what it was and
unfortunately there's a lot of guys I
shouldn't even say a lot there's a a
decent number of guys that don't do well
with alcohol man and it ruins their
lives that ruins their careers and that
sucks it sucks to see ya I never really
had any issues I drank when I drank and
never interfere with myself in any way
and you know that was it it wasn't a
huge deal and I mean of course what I
mean what I'm talking when I was 19 20
21 22 and we drank a lot we drank a lot
weird how your body legs make that laugh
yeah yeah the next morning we got up the
next morning Brasi like it was nothing
we and that's what we did but then like
I said and even now you know and I when
I go out and hang out with some of my
old buddies or actually it's more not
what I just what if I go and hang out
with some my old buddies you know we
probably don't even you know maybe have
a beer but when I go out and see the
young guys the young guys are getting
after it I don't look down on them at
all I think you know is getting after it
I found I found when I hung out with my
buddies that are still serving you're
not in the gig anymore you're not doing
the job so you're a little out of shape
you're your drills are a little rusty
maybe or whatever I find when I'm around
guys my age that are still operational I
can't keep up with them drinking because
it's part of the training it's part of
the culture I've fallen off and even
like before I was in I didn't really
drink and then when I got out I stopped
drinking as much you know and it's not
like again guys we're not Jocko and I
aren't saying in the military we're all
functional alcoholics what we're saying
is it's just what we do yeah and you
know and remember the job that we
volunteer to do we've Ahlan tr2 running
a gun fire
you know for our countries and for fun
like let's face it a lot of us think
it's fun I thought it was the best time
of my life but he's still got a blow off
that steam and booze is really good at
lubricating the the you know the the the
the machinery of blowing off steam so
when I when I started drinking for pain
though yeah is where I realized because
even the pills bro like let's go back to
my pills I didn't know I was addicted to
the pills until I watched intervention
and Billy was addicted to oxy cotton and
I was like I said this on the show last
time oxy cotton that sounds familiar
and I pick up the pill bottle that's
next to me and I go oh I'm on oxy cotton
and then they say the doses he takes are
this I'm like I'm on three times the
dose he's alone and I'm like that's when
I went I can get addicted to pills I get
it was so foreign to my brain that
doctor said doctor meet me and pain
doctor go here soldier take this and I
go okay and I take it no more pain go
fight more you know that's that's going
back to the alcohol thing is is one more
thing for me I was just about to say
this was I said hey look when back in
the day before the war started there was
like nothing else like nothing she was
gonna get drunk now
the younger guys they're smarter than we
were and they have a reason to be do
they have a reason to be there and they
have a reason not to drink they're like
hey bro I'm gonna go fight a war you
know like I want to be in shape I want
to be better I want to be faster I don't
want to get in a fight I don't want to
get a DUI so they're smarter than they
are and that part of the culture is
slowly changing and I think it's good
it's us I think it's awesome and I hope
it continues again I think it's it got
over emphasized when I first came in
over emphasized in the 90s it was like
but it was a way because we weren't
fighting anyone in exactly so you drink
to be a man then you fight each other
and if another platoon shows up you
fight those [__] guys of another
squad shows up or another company all
right band together I know we were just
fighting but we'll get back to that
there's a ret as an armored regiment
over there we're gonna go [__] those
guys there's something that I've been
thinking about on this subject it is in
the military right yeah and even in life
as a human
you want to prove that you're ready to
sacrifice yourself for the cause I'm
willing to make the sacrifice well in a
bizarre and the kind of unfortunate way
proving to Jodi that you know what
watch this Jodi I'm gonna drink 16 so
you're not fired
no you're not although you know I don't
care I don't have the perfect [__]
oh and I proved lineup 18 lineup 18 army
versus Navy let's go that's how it's
[__] way it goes echo echo you played
football yeah yeah you were talking
about that earlier boat or on the show
eyes listen to do we're taking a [__]
with no stalls and you say what's yeah
and football weed ripped the doors off
the stall oh yeah I don't care watch me
[__] what's what's more I'm trying the
words now way more apt to happen now as
a guy to be like hey I can clean and
jerk you know 285 what can you get yeah
and and so the guys are they're focused
on something that fits not focus on
their blowing out shoulders and yeah
we'll talk about that later but so but I
get what you're saying cuz in the
Canadian Forces we hadn't had a war
since Korea yeah and we had that what
combat we had as I was coming in was
being downplayed we had guys take it we
had a guy and this is history this is
proven he took an RPG round through his
chest like just to kill them obviously
and everything but his family's told he
was killed in a rollover because our
government was like they're supposed to
be peacekeeper wasn't indeed former
Yugoslavia I know a guy who took a
sniper round through the chest as a tank
commander he was told shut the [__] up
take your pension and your benefits got
full benefits like it didn't they didn't
downplay what you've got and if you're
wounded they just said don't you dare
tell anybody we had a we had a unit come
home after like fighting some of the
most intense combat in Europe since
World War two when the crow hats are
trying to go through a Serb area and
ethnically cleanse and this is in the
90s when the Canadian like rep for
peacekeeping really got which was known
since Egypt but came back because our
units and the French Foreign Legion
units were the only units that were like
[__] you were not moving
if you're gonna definitely cleanse
through here you're going through us
whereas all the other UN units ran away
and they were in four or five days of
like in
hence combat bunch of wounded no killed
thankfully but the government and the in
the end the chain of command were like
shut your [__] mouth go home like
nothing happened that's real that's real
bro Google made act pocket Canadian
Forces and you'll read all about these
dudes who just like basically we're like
hanging out drinking coffee smoking
butts and telling war stories that never
happened to being in a war and going
holy [__] a buddy of mine I get mad I
mean he put out a book called shadow
keeper or Ghost Keepers I'll get the
name sorry I know I know and he was the
first Canadian unit him and his unit
were the first Canadian 'its into Bosnia
and the [__] they saw and the things
they went through it's a great book by
the way ghost keepers why would he be
mad at you for talking about it
no no forgetting the name wrote oh sorry
about that but the point is that at that
time he was told like you don't tell we
don't we don't brag is what the line
that was told but really the government
back home was like we didn't know this
was gonna happen well that you don't
peace keep without bustin heads yeah
like there's a reason if you if I want
to go kill that guy and you're in my way
guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna try
and go through you right like I think
they think this concept of peacekeeping
you know was like you know like the guy
with the billy club are okay everybody
keep it down here see like that's kind
of what the politicians thought that was
for college kids sometimes yeah yes
smack went over the head with that billy
club like and I think and I remember my
first tour in Kosovo even we trained for
crowd control we trained for a whole lot
of things but then the final training
exercise is when we all went oh because
the Russians rolled in and took over the
airport in Kosovo I don't know if you
remember that yeah and we did a live
training exercise to a joint armored a
full combat team exercise like main
battle tanks firing and it like I'd
never my dick with rock-hard a you were
fight we've got 500 rounds on each other
it is like bullets flying everywhere end
like like rate the rangecontrol safety
was like minimal right because they're
like trying to simulate real combat
and then we got but anyway the point is
that when you don't have anything to
point your soldiers at they turn on each
other and that's what we were getting
earlier but to round out the whole like
what soldiers board soldiers are a
danger echo I think if you've been
around a group of active Navy SEALs I
think or maybe even army guys like yeah
they got nothing else to fight they'll
just fight each other yeah they did
we used to whenever we're waiting for a
plane to go on a trip like this before
my youngest like it would start off with
okay let's see who can hit that pole
over there with a rock yeah right and
then all of a sudden it's like okay
let's see you can hit the light with the
rock and then all of a sudden it's hey
let's see who can hit that car tire with
a rock and pretty soon yours car is it
whoever bunch of idiots
yeah pretty soon you're even a they're
having a rock fight right which is which
is not smart cuz you're Hawking rocks
and baseballs at each other or whatever
yeah and yeah we were talking about was
it the newer guys see how we did it but
they have an enemy though yeah
absolutely they have it we have a
perpetual enemy that is not going away
and so I see the guys that are in my
unit now they come in and they're like
okay what supplements are gonna keep me
at my best exactly like they read my
book they go okay so Jodie you'd stop
drinking coffee how many days before you
deployed I'd be like well at least five
days so it's out of my system because
when I'm out there getting after the
enemy I don't want to be having a
caffeine crash but if I need it
I want that peace did you ever get that
wake-up gum in your rats no it's like
four cups of coffee and one or two cups
of coffee and like when you need it like
I would keep that in my pocket till the
very end like the helo might be coming
to pick us up and if I didn't take it I
was happy but sometimes yeah you take
that in the middle of a mission and
you're like okay I got two more days in
me right but the point is like they have
something to aim themselves at right at
the beginning we didn't but even then
booze wasn't a big deal to me it was
just what we did like you said
fast-forward to this fall that would
just pass and I realize I'm crashing I
felt like every say - you're saying you
saw something oh you see because I kind
of cut you off you were talking about
seeing the
program where they show addicted people
what's that program called intervention
you spend imagine when I first got
wounded in oh seven and that's when I
realized I was addicted to the pills but
not addicted like I need a pill it was
like my body would just start reacting
and I would be like oh I'm itchy for
some reason and then that's when I
started easing off and I never took a
pill after Father's Day 2011 but even
that you read the book I ended up buying
pills from a guy in an alley once and I
went what the [__] is it like and the
system is treating me like an [__]
because I want more pills and then
they're like yeah you if you want more
pills you got to come to the hospital
every day to get your dose I'm like I'm
not a [__] junkie doc I just don't
let the dose you're giving me isn't
enough to keep me from feeling like [__]
and like and then I'm mitigating my
stress with the pills
so maybe okay so go to more therapy and
that's when I started rebuilding in 2011
so come the fall I'm still not on my
legs I he's right this is 2011 2011 when
I quit the pills God and that's why I
thought booze wouldn't be a problem
cigarettes aren't a problem booze isn't
a problem you lose I mean you'd quit
pills whatever it was like whatever when
the time comes for you to quit booze
you'll just quit that's what you were
thought when I'm ready I'll be done with
it and but what I what what happened and
if you're a politician the most
important thing federal state municipal
so it can enough state would be
provincial budget money money is the big
thing that everybody worries about in
private life and everything else so so
with what when are we talking about
right now sorry you're already bat
you're by now I'm bouncing around a
little bit I'm just saying in my mind
2017 wasn't that big a deal as far as
the drinking because I'd kicked all
these other habits and I whether it's
real or not I had an army psychologist
once tell me I had an anti addictive
personality because I guess like you
like to me it's like okay well what's
gonna help me function better what's
gonna get me to the next day without too
many issues and if I want to have a few
drinks I can have a few drinks and I can
because tomorrow morning I don't have to
be anywhere until 9:00 a.m. anyway so
whatever if I'm a little hungover when I
get there I'll have a coffee and a glass
of water or Gatorade and an Advil not a
big deal
fast-forward to
again my daughter's birthday last fall
Oh daddy can't be there yet because I'm
still hungover right I got my cup I and
I and it was when I realized I'm going
through I was like I felt this before
because I kept asking myself what why do
I keep screwing everything up and then
the budgets process started that's where
I was going with this and that's where I
remembered I'm not because you're Jocko
you're not a private citizen anymore you
know that right what do you mean well if
you fell off Instagram tomorrow there's
a million people out there I'd probably
like where the [__] is Jocko and I was
toasting les I was being less upbeat and
what I did post the few last couple
podcasts even going back to the spring
on one of them we got loaded and we said
it was for fun but I like I needed a
drink myself and I'm starting to miss
budget and budget is money that's what
everything runs on the City of Ottawa
has a three and a half billion dollar
budget
why isn't councillor Minich at the
budget meeting for the community
Protective Services Committee community
Protective Services Committee oh he's
not feeling well
his legs are bugging him stuff like
whatever my staff said I'm telling
they're asking me what's going on boss
and I'm like yeah I just think I need
you to buy me some time but that's when
the media and the voter goes no no no we
get it you like to write books and you
like to do podcast you like to shoot
guns and you know you're a dude and we
and we accept you as who you are but our
four-year commitment the biggest part of
that commitment is making sure that
money is spent properly and on the
things that we want it spent on and we
elected you to be that voice why aren't
you at that meeting and personal private
matters can only get you so far during
like the most important part of your job
right well either go on medical leave or
be at the meeting is basically what I
was told right get a doctor's note or be
here and that's when I ended up doing
that radio interview in December when it
really came to a head and when I had to
really admit to myself like I'm border I
think I was in my mind I was borderline
alcoholic
I guess but I was I was just not able to
deal with that failure in myself how
much how much were you drinking at the
peak it was a 40 ounce of whatever I get
my hands on sometimes it was like to
remember one time it was to 26 ounce
bottles of rye Crown Royal was my brand
of choice and if that wasn't around
again Jack Daniel and you're drinking
you're getting done with work and that's
it you know at this point I just waking
up in the morning and drinking okay so
he was on a work like I was just I knew
in the morning I couldn't go and then
you feel like [__] cuz you drank all day
so what do you do you go for the hair of
the dog and that just turns into a
perpetual circle and then the wounds I
was talking about earlier they're not
healing because my body is full of
alcohol and a friend of mine said you
know what my dad used to have that
problem because he drank too much too
and he would like cut his hand working
on like wood work and the shed and it
would be there for like six eight nine
months and then he'd sober up for a
couple months and then it would go away
but then he'd fall back and I went your
dad the maniac you've told me stories
about and she was like yeah and I'm like
okay so this is really becoming a
problem so now I'm dealing with the
internal struggle of I'm a complete
failure of a human being I've met failed
my kids I failed the voters I failed
like friends of mine like Jocko and EKKO
who you know we expect certain things
from each other right or we think we do
and you could you could have a terrible
day and I would never judge you for it
but you don't know that until it happens
right and even if you know that you
still don't want to admit it never mind
a Jocko or Eko
how about to yourself right and again
I'd stop meditating I'd stop going to my
therapist I'd stop going to the gym I'd
stop podcasting I'd stopped writing
really even though and then during the
book tour in October I know I'm
rewinding a little bit but I the last
thing I wanted to do was go in the book
to her but the book is coming out and
that's a commitment that I signed and
you know you're dealing with all this
and I did the tour in my wheelchair and
everybody's like oh you're doing so much
better because you're okay with being in
the wheelchair and I think yeah yeah
cool close the hotel room door and like
open a drink
right have a drink so December was the
worst month of my life getting blown up
was easy
in my opinion dealing with this [__] but
what I didn't do in 2007 was actually
deal with the fact that I was blown up
frankly I was so like yeah I recover be
useful to the regiment be useful the
Queen get better for the country put
prosthetic legs on life as normal ish
and then now I'm like okay first of all
now dude you're 40
second of all you have kids that are now
like we're the like I would see them and
they'd be like we miss you like where
have you been like why aren't you around
more and like you don't live far away
like what's your Excuse because oh
because I'm ashamed of you seeing me all
dealing with the next day of being drunk
and stuff you know and Nick and it
really it really it really became I
understand now I've always been
sympathetic to addicts since my oxycotin
days but now I get how depression can
really make you into someone not worth
saving in your own mind and I get I get
it and I've never dis I've never thought
hatefully or anything of friends that
have committed suicide or have gone down
that path of depression that you just if
you're not in it you don't get it and
you go man why can't you just like read
a book or listen to some comedy or not
drink today like have I'll sit with you
and have a water and you just don't get
it and I was doing a lot of this on my
self isolation too because you don't
want anyone seeing you like this and
then the few people that do hang around
are often in the same in one of the
levels of [__] up live [__] up
and so you know I've talked about this
before where and it sounds like you're
describing exactly I talked about how
like people get into a place where
they're basically in a storm right there
there's a storm all around their head
and no matter which direction they look
they just see clouds and thunder and
rain and horror right and everybody
that's outside that storm looks at a
minute go well yeah you're in a storm
just come over here and you'll be out of
the storm just move over here and you'll
be out of the storm yeah just put down
the drink or you know start working out
again or whatever you just move over
here and you'll be out of the storm yeah
but but that person can't see they can't
see the rushes everything around them is
a storm they don't understand how me
coming over there is like climbing a
mountain and not to give anyone [__] but
maybe a little bit of [__] if you know
who you are
hey man want to watch UFC tonight at my
place yeah cool except hey bro I'm in a
wheelchair I can't even get in your
front door can you come to my place
where I can get around and take a piss
without getting out of water bottle and
you know like being embarrassed in front
of your wife yeah but you live all the
way over there like where you've already
got plans and [__] like well cool what
about next weekend and that kind of that
didn't help as well cuz people like they
don't like even coming here you're like
oh I'll just buddy carry up the stairs
and I'm like yeah I trust you but at the
same time like some of my friends are
offering to carry me into their house
say like 140 pounds like soaking wet
never been in lifted weight in their
life and nothing against them but it's
like you want me to trust my physical
safety or you could just come to my
place mmm like like and they don't get
it and I don't I'm not mad at anyone
about it it's like it's like that's
saying like I don't hate them about it
but at the same time it's kind of like
alright cool man I'll just watch the
fight and we can text and I'll be at my
place alone again right like because I
didn't leave my dog isn't that the place
where I'm at right now right so that all
thing just kind of fell into a big
blender and in December how long did
that so did this when you got back in
your wheelchair yeah you gave up the
legs yeah this is really this is me it's
so in Maine when you like I said you won
that long trip you went to Albany you
come back from that now you're now
you're like I'm done with my prosthetics
they're freakin killing me yeah and I'm
getting in a wheelchair back in the
wheelchair is that sort of like now
you're just you now you're just gaining
momentum going downhill oh yeah well
then but does it
crazy things I thought I'm starting to
climb up because I'm like finally
admitting I can't wear my prosthetics
because I would like walk into council
which is the big like every two weeks
you'd do the big meeting and that's
where all like all everything you went
to the bar and drank about and then went
to the my office and like argued behind
the scenes with each other now you sit
down and you go all those in favor aye
all those against you know nay and then
it's passed all resolution passes and
now it's a legal deed ice cream on Bank
Street on Sundays which is a bylaw in
Ottawa that I'm gonna actually try and
get changed by the way from like 1800s
but the point is that's the big show
they give all the other training right
like that's the live-fire exercise or
that's the actual OP right so that's
what your work for so when I started
missing those at the end of the year
when we're Pat like the budget is the
thing that if without budget you have
you guys just had a government shutdown
over budget no that's you're trying to
avoid and that's when the media who you
know they're doing their job but Jodie
medic and a headline gets clicks and now
Jodie Minich the guy everybody loves oh
he's [__] up what's going on here one
guy even made a video called no show
medic because I'd missed like four or
five meetings but the meetings I had
missed were the ones out like you could
miss every other meeting throughout the
year and nobody would give a fine [__]
of a rolling doughnut which is the same
out of a book a series of books I love
but but I miss these three meetings oh
no oh no man like these are the meetings
we really voted for you to be at where
you at no show medic and this guy is
trying to make a name for himself as a
political commentator whatever he's an
[__] but point is say that [__] to my
face the point is he's right though mmm
where is no show medic and now in my
because that's what I wasn't my head
already right and then I'm like okay so
I thought if I said personal family
matters or personal health matters they
get it they know me they know I'm
dealing with stuff along the way but
they're like yeah we get it man but if
you don't tell us what's going on and
then we're gonna assume you're just
[__] late being lazy cuz why doubt
why shouldn't we
and I went okay and a reporter buddy of
mine and I sent you a couple texts
that's when I and I when you said that
earlier I my skin went like you know
we've got the goose bump because I
forgot I sent that and I was starting to
think like okay I got to go back to
basics I gotta remember who I am and
what I was and my own advice and that's
when I went oh yeah I got too
comfortable in my pity and the enemy now
is on my left flank and I have zero
defenses on the left flank
and what are you instead of fighting a
shitty losing rearguard you turn and you
face the [__] you face the battle so
I turned and a reporter friend of mine
and for the record reporters are not
really friends they're those friends
that you kind of keep at arm's length
and you're always ready to punch but you
never know right
not really punch but I'm not threatening
anyone with violence you PCWorld weirdos
but the he said he called me on a
personal note and he said hey man here's
what's being said in the in the in the
media world about you and this is what
could be going to headline if you don't
say anything soon I know an okay well
some of that's true some of that's made
up but that's what you do when you don't
know and I said all right can I come on
your show and he's like well that's what
I was just about to ask you if you want
come on my show and that's Evan and we
and then we went and we talked about it
and he was very kind to me he's rough
he's a tough dude he's a tough reporter
but at the same time very fair and he
hit me with a few with a few hits and I
hit him back but what I did was I got it
all out of my system because it
basically you feel like you're holding
never mind I'm keeping a secret from
Jocko and echo I'm keeping a secret from
40,000 residents who trust me to be
their counselor then there's all the
fans of Jody medic that are out there
and all the supporters who are all
amazing and who all are willing to
support you through the best and the
worst of times but they can't support
you without anything that they like to
them I just stopped podcasting for no
reason and I've stopped being positive
on social media so what like what that
you just decide is this the real Jody
now is
who like it were you faking it before
like that's some of the messages I got
like all obviously you figured out that
you can still make money and be be the
[__] you actually are and I was like
oh [__] geez it may be I am that [__]
but when I did my buddy show a huge
weight went off my shoulders I shouldn't
say buddy but you know but the point is
that that was the beginning of me
turning into the end of the fight
instead of running and I had a couple of
setbacks so so hold on so this show that
you did and you you said you listened I
didn't into it but the the the premise
of the show was what you did for lack of
a better word is you took ownership of
everything that was going on I even
laughed I was laughing right before I
went online I went on to the show I said
I'm doing a joke when I'm taking extreme
ownership you own this
so you went on there and you said well
I'd like a baby by the way anyone who
thinks is a tough guy I've been drinking
too much
yeah what do you like what were the
facts that what were the things that you
took ownership of was that night that
was a major thing right well the the
booze caused a lot of the lack of energy
lack of attempted attendance went down
because it's one thing to be buzzed it's
another thing to be completely hungover
and [__] up and show up for meeting
like you you didn't know yourself I know
myself and I know like if I go in there
like this right now people will be like
he is completely [__] right and I know
I'm swearing a lot and I apologize but
you avoid that and then so I said okay
guys well here's why I missed this
meeting and here's why I missed that
meeting because I've turned to an old
friend Crown Royal instead of my
therapist and my doctors and my friends
and my family my supporters and all the
things that made me able to cope from
two thousand seven to two thousand
seventeen so for basically a decade I
forgot about and I left behind like
never mind I was never minded like
stopped the gym stopped talking to my
therapist stopped talking to my kids
stopped talking to my ex but stopped
talking to my mom stopped talking to my
dad my friends again I was self
isolating and
there were times when I'd want to pick
up the phone and just call it you or Rob
or are some of my friends at home or
some of my sniper buddies and just be
like I don't know what to do and now
you're man echo right sure
imagine trying to make that call yeah
and I'm not saying it's a man problem
saying it's a hit definitely a human
problem but I'm the guy everybody thinks
I get told you're the poster child of
success post-injury and I'm like in my
head I'm like I'm a [__] bullshitter
like that's how you feel and I'm like
whether I am or not I've been lucky and
I've made a few decent decisions I'm for
my own accord and I am where I am
through hard work and discipline and now
what and now I feel like I'm losing it
all because I have I have I been faking
it was this just a ride that I was on
and now I'm done and I want to get off
like the thing the things that go
through your head now first of all I was
never suicidal
I never thought never crossed my mind I
don't know why I just didn't but I I did
have one thought one day where I went I
think I understand why some guys take
that path though I had a such a day one
day where it was in December and I it
wasn't like I thought Oh things would be
better if I was dead it was like I just
I was at such a low moment and I went I
think I get it why sometimes guys take
that path because it's just like you
know like it was just such an extreme
combination of everything from all sides
and I went I think I kind of get it now
because before I don't know about you
but I've tried to figure out why some of
the guys go that route and I just can't
but that moment I went okay I kind of
get it and it was it wasn't like I
thought solution for myself but I I just
they visit very quick cuz it took about
two minutes of in and out and it's stuck
with me though because I went that's the
first time I've ever had any thought
like that right and then so my
daughter's birthday is late December and
I missed that one too and then New
Year's Eve and I've already made plans
you go and do an assessment that would
tell me how terrible of an addict I am
as an alcoholic because that's what you
are you're an addict and I'm going to a
a kind of sorta and I have a sponsor
who's all over me he's a great guy and I
won't say his name here but he knows who
he is and he's a beautiful human being
and he's trying to get on top of me and
Luke's trying to get on top of me and my
mom and my ex and my friends and they're
all trying to just be like okay man like
we get it now we've heard we've heard
your calls loud and clear now how do we
help you and then it's trying to like
mitigate that and then well it's you
know it's Christmas I'll have a few
drinks I know I told the world this but
you know I can handle it I'm not I'm not
that bad and then the next morning
you're like oh man but then New Year's
Eve I had some company that came out
because they're like we heard you man
we're here it's New Years Eve let's hang
out let's beef have fun we'll have a few
drinks we're all here to keep an eye on
you can't get that but we know who you
are and the next morning it's like I did
what because now all the pressures on
now to get better and I was hearing
radio interviews were there I was
headline news in Ottawa for a couple
days where they went wow real brave of
him to say that now how is he gonna get
better guys are talking about me I have
to retire or resign from politics in
Canada with the gun laws as they are a
public said anyone can call in a threat
on anybody who owns guns right so some
gun hating citizen and I'm not hating
them for this I'm just hating them for
being a dick I said oh I can get a
prominent gun owners guns taken away if
I call the police and say I think he's a
threat to public safety and that's all
you have to do it's completely anonymous
which is [__] and anyone can do it
against anyone that's a gun owner and so
now the police call and they say listen
we have to do an investigation so like
so that actually happens so this was
this was right before New Year's Eve so
I'm like freaking out I am losing my
[__] and because I'm like I don't know
how it works now they're very
understanding but they have to do the
check they look once an investigation
started real or not
substantiated or not we gotta go through
the steps one does it okay so they go
inspect the guns they the guns are safe
the guns are where they're supposed to
be everything's locked I everything's
proper dead today talk to my family
nope he's never been threatening with
them that Allah Allah and then like and
then and then in the New Year's Eve
rolls around and I have that's terrible
this is the last I'd the last drop of
booze I had was New Year's Eve and we
started with a small bottle and I drank
it all myself and and this past New
Year's he just passed new zvex old
George today 21 and tours ago 23 days
ago and the next morning I got a little
bit of a lowdown about what I was like
and I call him evil Jody and he came out
once in 2005 after my first deployment
to Afghanistan him before my second one
where I got wounded and I was bouncing
at the time and I was you know having
some little bit too much fun in life
maybe but I was also drinking too much
for the wrong reasons at the time and a
lot of us were cuz we had the KN forces
we hadn't dealt with you know combat a
lot right like I said and a lot of us
were green when we went into Afghanistan
the first time so maybe a lot MIT like
you said a fair number of us me included
were maybe choosing the wrong ways I was
still meditating all that so mitigated a
little bit but this I call him evil Jody
he came out my friend why one one of my
buddies who still talk to he's a Police
sniper now but he pulled me aside and he
said hey man like I've never ever seen
you act like that ever no matter how
drunk you were what it was going on or
how angry you were who pissed you off
what the [__] was that about and I went
oh that sounds like Grandpa or whatever
so I locked him in a cage and I used to
joke that you know don't let don't let
the caveman out of his cage and then but
that night so the twenty five days ago
or whatever was he got out and I didn't
hurt anybody and or anything in it but I
said things you don't shouldn't and I
maybe made actions that you shouldn't
yeah and for me the biggest thing is
when you you realize that you had no
control over what's happening and how
about even remember yeah well that's
what I'm saying I did all these things I
said what to whom oh my god and you're
just like your thing
like and I called so I called one of the
people that was there and I said I am so
sorry and he was like been there done
that dude you got to get your [__]
together
I'll be here when you're done when
you're ready or I'm here tomorrow he was
such a great guy about it and I went oh
so the world doesn't hate you for being
a [__] and I get that helped too we
talked about this last night like who
when you mitigate crisis David Letterman
or Tiger Woods
whoever like don't follow the Tiger
Woods book go with David Letterman
always explain what David Letterman did
cuz I did so yeah so in in in in a
nutshell David Letterman got he got
caught an affair on his wife David
Letterman by the way is like a talk show
host at night and he was he's all not
yeah he's not anymore but I guess he was
and he was pretty popular at some point
yeah it was are some people who don't
know is a golf player so he yeah if you
haven't heard of him he's like yeah he's
like half black half tie and you know he
swung a golf club pretty good for a
minute but he got caught cheating on his
wife too but so David Letterman got a
blackmail letter right before one of his
shows and the guy said I know what
happened that it had you having an
affair or something he had had one or he
was having one and it was like pay me 40
thousand dollars a week for the rest of
my life or this or something I'll tell
the world and David Letterman went
alright I [__] up and he went out and
he stand I don't remember it but I don't
remember exactly how it went but
basically usually they do a monologue
these guys before their show and he went
instead of today's monologue I'm gonna
look into the camera and I'm gonna say I
cheated on my wife and she knows about
it and we're working on it and somebody
else found out and they thought they
were gonna get money from me so he
looked in the camera man [__] you
the police are coming to your house
right now and to the rest of you I
apologize I'm sorry
i mighta my wife I apologize and I
understand if this is a problem for us
and then we will have to deal with it
again because of Who I am
its world news and he he owned it mmm he
owned all of it and the other day he
interviewed this guy named Obama you
might have heard of him on his new show
on Netflix called
I forget what the next guest or
something and he was on he's still seen
as a good dude
right cuz he owned it and he and he
worked through it and he and he didn't
not talk about it and then there's what
Tiger Woods did which is run away hide
not admit anything and he Tiger Woods
went through for five years of just
complete chaos in his life before he
finally even I think now he still places
in the bottom 50 I think he's at the PGA
I don't know I'm still plays but he
probably just plays to pay the bills now
he was worth a billion dollars at one
point and he lost it all because of not
owning a [__] he probably still would
have lost a lot of it because his wife
took half but regardless sponsors
dropped him he himself as a human being
couldn't look himself in the mirror I'm
sure right and blah blah blah so I said
okay well this is my Tiger Woods or
David Letterman moment like going on the
radio I thought was it now or two weeks
later ish whatever it was yeah two weeks
later and I'm like well either I never
drink again or I continue down the path
of bullshitting myself into saying well
I'll just get better when I'm ready and
this journey I've been on for since I
left what did I leave I forget
Jan 18 or 19 I left Ottawa and I've just
been driving I wanted to drive route 66
since I was a teenager and you know that
I talked to the kids I talked to Atlanta
I talked to my mom I talked to everybody
that mattered I said I'll be back first
City Council is January 31st after our
Christmas break anyway
and I said I'll be back I'm gonna go
visit some people that are gonna look me
in the eye and tell me if I'm full of
[__] or not you guys be in some of them
and when I get back I'm gonna my
therapist I already have an appointment
my my doctor's for my legs because I'm
going back to basic training to learn
how to use prosthetics again so I don't
go through those issues again I'm gonna
talk about my addiction issues I'm gonna
talk about why I'm not I'm going back to
the gym I have a diet plan already have
a trainer waiting I'm going back to the
base I'm back I'm a basic training to be
human being again and I I was I was
laughing this morning listening to your
show about the basic training at Marine
Corps Base in Parris Island because I
was like [__] man I just I keep doing
this every three or four years like I
got to go back and relearn what it's
like to be Jody medic because I am
evolving you know I had to evolve beyond
the soldier and then I had to prepare in
a citizen and then I don't now I'm
turning into something else I think
because I had a plan
until I was 44 I thought at 25 years in
the Army or 20 was 27 years retire
become a contractor teach shooting for
the rest of my life and just be that
grumpy old guy that you know if you want
to know mo shoot and you talked that guy
be good decent money right I didn't want
to get rich I just wanted to pay my
bills and hang out with my my dream
retirement was gonna be to hurt alpacas
around on my horse with my rifle shoot
coyotes and and listen to like gangster
rap and read books like that was it that
was what I wanted to do but but life has
a funny way of pointing you in
directions that maybe you need to go in
or you didn't know you had to go and I'm
back on the jaakko podcast spilling my
whole life and my soul out for everybody
in I hope somebody learns if we keep one
troop from Legolas and I even if you're
on the road where you know you're
[__] up pull over
call in air support like Jocko said like
you got we have so many resources we
don't know about and you know we all on
the lone wolf well even the lone wolf
runs in a pack and I think that's how
I've thought it like you know the soft
guys you know we're all alphas but we're
in teams you know and I rolled in a team
of three hardcore guys there's me and my
boys and but we at the same time I knew
I had artillery support I had air cover
I had this I had another sniper team
covering the flank over there and recce
platoon over there and you're never
alone and even last night like I I felt
bad I I'm still in a t-shirt I drove in
all day from the t-shirt I worried the
day before and he showed out I've never
seen Jocko dressed up and I'm like oh
[__] jock was like in a button-down
shirt he's wearing let's not get crazy I
had on a pair of jeans vans a t-shirt
and a flannel shirt that's I'm like I'm
like okay so I haven't seen him seen you
in two years
ish give or take a few months we've
talked but it's not like we've been on
the phone for hours I've been like hey
bro what's going now like you know I you
were busy dudes we kept in touch the
wait guys I guess do but we sat down and
I'm like okay do I eat dinner and then
tell him tomorrow or and I just
basically threw up all over you and you
and you were awesome and I love you for
it and I appreciate it but I needed that
hour of just talking about myself and I
felt bad about it took us I'm like I
haven't asked him how his kids are you
have I have friends that'll do you we're
willing to do that for and I've done
that for hundreds of guys but then when
it's you doing the talking man it's
tough and I get it now I get it now more
than anything so guys yeah you gotta
pull over you gotta like you just got to
take a knee and let somebody else take
point for a bit and that's just the way
it is you know you were said you said
you kind of understand when people feel
suicidal you know I know and I've said
that a bunch of times since it happened
what's your question sorry like do you
do you because I think about that too
sometimes where that's the only time
I've ever had that so I don't think
about me people like what does it take
to be like you know what I'm gonna in my
life my question is do you think that
it's like that feeling is like it's
almost like this immense boredom with
you know how like you
you just don't know it's not like this
pain that I gotta end it's more that
like there's really no reason for me to
it's like you're going up this hill but
the hill isn't that steep but it's just
yeah you know I think that's part of it
yeah like it's it's like from what I've
read the few suicide notes that I've
seen when you know when you find like we
had one I don't know I talked about it
on the show last time we I was teaching
on a sniper course and one of the guys I
was talking to him at one moment about
what we're gonna do Saturday because
they're all guys you work with right
it's it's kind of like I'm sure it's the
same as the SEALs a lot of them that
come on the sniper course anyway our
guys you've picked out of the platoons
and then you know even if they pass you
still have a meeting where you go okay
do we really want to work with that go
guys like I know we gave him the badge
but are we gonna let him into the team's
and then so this is one of the guys so
you know I'm getting to know him a
little bit more he's from the other
battalion and yeah cool man I know this
girl in town and this and that okay
right on and 20 minutes later we're like
what the [__] did he go we're doing roll
call where the [__] is he and we found
him hanging from one of the you know the
pavilions are out in the training area
gets shade during lectures so he was out
there and we find this letter on his
pillow and I'm reading and it's about
they they feel like they're in this pain
that's never ending yeah and I don't
think it's boredom I think it's just
this it's the no light at the end of the
tunnel feeling yeah yeah as you were
asking that question that the word I
wrote down was was because we've been
talking about her we've heard from it
from the last couple podcasts that we
did and it's the same thing you just
said it's hope so
when you don't have any hope that this
is gonna end when you don't see any
light at the end of the tunnel and like
I said when you're when you're stuck in
this storm and everywhere you look you
don't see the light at the end of the
aisle you don't see that this cloud ends
somewhere and it goes thundering
lightning will subside you just are in a
storm no matter where you look there's a
storm and they say you know there's no
hope of getting out of this storm and I
think that's where that's where they
start and luck to having those luckily
you know when it when the thought
entered my mind like I get it and what
I'm again I never thought of suicide but
I had the thought go through my brain
where I go I get why some people might
see this as an option yeah because I did
see like
because I'm texting him I'm texting Rob
I'm texting you know my buddies in the
can Soph I'm my regimental friends my my
mom my dad my brother most of the people
that should be aware there's a problem
were aware yeah so I still had lots of
light coming in but it was my now it's
your choice are you gonna go towards it
or are you gonna stay floating where you
are I guess is a way like are you gonna
reach for the line are you gonna sit
there like it's just out of harm to
reach yeah you know I talked about
detachment all the time and this is like
another situation where obviously when
you're when you're wrapped up in those
kind of emotions right you you you can't
see anything else somebody that's
outside there they're perfectly clear
can help guide you out of that even
though that's gonna be hard and there's
things did not understand and all that
but they can at least they know that
they're outside that and they can see it
just like on the battlefield somebody
that's at elevation you know you get
building yeah some guys though left go
left go legs and then go right you're
like [__] yeah so if you can reach out
to somebody that can that has a little
bit better altitude on the battlefield
that you're in then and if you can reach
out to them say hey man I can't see
what's going on all I see is darkness
point me in the right direction and
they're gonna tell you some dumb [__]
like hey okay let's get you to a doctor
let's get you stop drinking let's get
you in the gym again they're gonna tell
you some stuff that sounds stupid it's
sound well it sounds way too easy yeah
sounds way too easily you think it's
that easy for [__] like that but you
know what I what I like what you said is
you're like man I keep having to go back
to boot camp yeah and it's like that's
really if you think about what boot camp
is what is boot camp they're like okay
put your shoes on like this
make your bed like that eat this food do
this workout that's what they do that
get you on the program that Lee it's
it's a little success and it leads to
having your life somewhat sorted out and
once you get that then you look around
you go okay now these bigger problems I
if I can control these little things I
can control this this thing that's a
little bit bigger if I can control that
I can control this thing that's a little
bit bigger I can control that that I
control this other things a little bit
bigger but
you're not you know it's the same thing
I talk about all the time with the with
the Chechens and the Russians not you
know failing on that first war and it
all started when they stopped shaving
well it's the same thing with your
personal life when you when you
disregard these these fundamental things
that you would do in boot camp yeah when
you start letting them go well then if
the little things fall apart then the
bigger things fall apart but contrary to
that when you put the little things
together you can start putting the
bigger things together and after that
you're doing this whole podcast I've
talked about what did I stop doing I
stopped oh well [__] I'm gonna eat pizza
tonight instead of my prescribed diet
that I have to ate four years and makes
me feel good and keeps me in good shape
because [__] it today and then the next
day it's like why I did it yesterday I'm
gonna have cocoa puffs for breakfast and
it was just a downward spiral of I don't
need to go see my therapist he's all the
way on the other tannins town and I know
my life sucks right now don't need
somebody to tell me that my life sucks
our you know hey what do you talk about
with the therapists what do they talk
about what do you do there so I'm
assuming you've never know uh honestly
like II just bounce life off them I mean
is if you got a guy that's listening
right now yeah
that's like oh no is it embarrassing not
even embarrassing if you got a guy
that's listening right now that's going
well what the hell would a therapist
tell me why would I not just you know
write in a journal or do something like
that do that too okay I write in a
journal which I again which I stopped
doing again the writing in the journal
is like yourself check because I go back
I was reading through my just kept a
journal throughout the year kinda but
you know not as often as you should and
I was reading through and I'm like wow
I'm even bullshitting myself in this my
last therapy session which is right
before the downward angle started he
said a few things to me that needed to
be said and I kind of took it to heart I
guess I got [__] but basically he said
you're putting a lot of work into being
Jodie midok and I was I [__] you man you
don't even know you don't even know but
like listen like this is over a year ago
and right now I'm like I'm still like
ouch that hurt but he was right and it
took me this whole time
to get to the point where I'm leveling
off now but therapy is you know um yeah
I think I said this to you last night
it's like Tiger Woods hey tiger would
bad example on how to mitigate crisis
but had a golf coach his whole career
and guess when he started sucking when
he stopped seeing his golf coach no one
is an expert on life I didn't have PTSD
when I got wounded I was cleared two
different therapists and a psychiatrist
both said clear to PTSD massive
depression which is normal for losing
even a loved one right and when they use
when you lose a limb they say it's like
losing a loved one so two loved ones
died when it but whatever whatever but
PTSD can come back we hope in Canada we
call it operational stress injury which
I was diagnosed with which is like an
injury so if you sprain your ankle or
break your ankle it's an injury one
heals differently from the other right
left alone they both lead to failure
your ankle will completely deteriorate
and fall off and have to be cut out of
the body or replaced if you don't treat
it if your I don't know what you guys
call Humvee or what do you call it truck
yeah Humvee Hummer if your Hummer blows
an axle do you yell at it and tell it
there's toughen up and go have a [__]
drink
no you send it in for [__]
maintenance yeah and I used to say this
the troops all the time I'll say it
again and I've said it before I've said
this to Colonels and Generals like dude
man if you need maintenance going go to
the [__] maintenance shop which is in
our case the [__] mind guy I had a
talk with the chief of Defense staff
which is our not sector just after the
chair of the Joint Chiefs yeah and we
were talking about combat units and I
said well you know and we were both
getting on the floss philosophically
siteís things samurai used to meditate
and practice and they do practice
calligraphy to perfect it and the tea
ceremony ain't warrior monks of Europe
would meditate would pray and fast the
mongolian hordes even had their
ceremonies where they purged the demons
and
what do our modern soldiers do there's
no self reflection there's no meditation
there's no we got to start from basic
training I've said I don't know if I
said this on the last podcast if I did I
apologize
I forgot my own advice again what's rice
rice for your body Oh rest out ice
compression elevation that's taught to
you the first day of basic training
because you're on I remembered it ah
right but that's your vehicle right and
your vehicle loves your body that gets
you into combat which is where the unit
needs you which is where your country
wants you what's rice for the mind and
this is where we all as a society have
to go back and think about these things
like jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu yeah it is it
is right to serve but this is my point
so when you go to a therapist if you
have no jiu-jitsu in your life you don't
have surfing you don't have calligraphy
you don't know how to meditate this
could be the beginning of you learning
how to be of the beginning of learning
rice for your mind and that's how I look
at it but even still I know enough about
medicine that I can take care of myself
for the most part without going to the
doctor but guess what now and then I hit
something and I go [__] I need a doctor
so therapy it doesn't mean you have to
go every week on border like clockwork
but have someone that your that's your
therapist or your psychiatrist or
whoever whatever level you need or you
qualify for in your benefits and that
doesn't mean you go see them all the
time I had a guy that I saw when I had
to but a lot of it is up to you to the
individual is still a big part of this I
as an individual this is where it hit me
really hard and when you heard the
emotion of my voice on the radio that
day I stopped even paying attention to
myself and I as an individual failed
myself my friends my sorry myself my
family so my daughters my ex my mom my
dad everyone who loves me for who I am
no matter what I do and then I failed
everyone around me that my friends you
guys and this is how you feel because I
didn't as an individual take ownership
of the problem so now I am and I'm going
back to therapy I'm going back to the
gym I'm back on my diet I know I don't
look it but hey I'm on the road and you
know those little powdered donuts and
the little thing with a coffee while
you're driving delicious
outstanding are you talking about the
chocolate-covered ones those ones too I
found those ones at a gas station in
like Texas somewhere and they are Don
that's bro we don't have those things in
Canada they have in America Dunkin donut
doughnuts might be better than Tim
Hortons I'm gonna go ahead and say
they're better oh and any Canadian that
wants to fight me Tim Hortons is owned
by a Brazilian company now so whatever
the point is I'm getting back to that
life that led me that kept me in check
because getting your legs blown off as a
rough go and I'll tell you that right
now but it's not impossible
but like any injury I have a spot in my
back like mid-back just below the
shoulder blades that I hurt when I was
14 and I felt it in basic I felt it
throughout my whole career but you work
on the muscles around it and you learn
to mitigate its impact on your daily
life mental injuries are the same and I
can tell you yeah I was cleared of PTSD
which is like the extreme mental injury
but I did have a mental injury and I
forgot that and then I had physical
injuries on top of it that I basically
ignored you know like even the mayor of
Ottawa he'd be like hey Jodie you're
limping today what's going on I didn't
think you're gonna make it to this event
this is before I the wheels fell off I
go yeah I'm air yeah you know I was
feeling a little pain and I know I don't
have to be here today but then I
remembered yeah I'm not a [__] so I'm
here and he's laughs like Oh Jodie
you'reyou're a unique politician that's
for sure but what I'm saying is like I'm
too stupid to stay home tonight so that
tomorrow morning I can feel better and
go to the gym play with my kids like
that you know what I mean like it's too
too too tough to be that dumb yeah so a
lot of this clearly is ego bro a
[__] and it's funny because
that's our fathers all-time but like
obviously you wouldn't be who you were
and have done what you've done if you
didn't have an ego that drove you that
want me made you want to be that mean
why would anyone
themselves to going to Sniper school
yeah it sounds like a cool job it's it's
a shitty job it sucks it's hard to do
but guess what your ego you're like I
want to do that I like the best Donnie
Wahlberg shows you the sexiest part of
the job which is shooting bad guys yeah
it is like so rare by the way like yeah
the rest of the job ah so so you
wouldn't have done I mean that the books
the politicians the pocket everything
that you've done there's there's some
element of ego that drives it obviously
you want to serve and it well you
wouldn't be if it was just pure ego you
wouldn't be able to do it either because
you you have to have a will to serve and
a desire to serve your country and your
brothers in arms so that's true too but
just take it to the next level you gotta
have some ego driving and then what
that's that thing that can drive you to
success can also drag you down when you
start saying I can do anything I can get
through this I can cut through this yeah
you need help I can keep on this path I
can quit drinking whenever I want those
are all things well your your your your
your ego is your biggest enemy but you
are your own biggest critic as well
Jocko I'm sure you have these thoughts
like your any other human being like if
I fail anyone today the person I don't
want to fail is myself because you have
an expectation of yourself and I know I
know enough about you and I you know we
are the enough of the same guy as much
as we were different that the biggest
person I'm trying to live up to
expectations are my own so when you get
up at 4 a.m. every day again god damn it
I wish I could but I'm not built that
bro I like to sleep I don't have to if I
don't want to anyway but like see listen
right now like I can get up at 3:30 I
[__] want to okay I just don't want
to I don't have to I can get all my [__]
done in 8 hours okay
Jocko but your ego is the one that goes
I can do that and then your critic is
the one that goes when you can't [__]
and if you fail the first critic that's
there looking at is the one when you
look in the mirror and you go I would do
it man I would [__] do I would look
in the mirror I stopped like the like
because you know I like I keep a bit of
a beard most times my beard got big and
then it started growing in here and
that's when you know something's up with
somebody
no I'm serious right now okay
I wouldn't look in the mirror because
when I looked in the mirror I saw
someone who went you drank last night
again didn't you [__] loser
good job yeah why don't you shower and
go and work so this this started coming
in because even if I looked in the
mirror was just enough to be okay I'm
not a complete mess run out the door my
hair grew it's it's it's weird man I can
I'm trying to write this down because I
even if it doesn't come out for anybody
but myself
it's it I didn't go through with the
legs
losing the legs and I did go through
losing my legs again but a whole other
thing bunch of stuff was happening like
realizing I know I said the soldier is
dead but maybe I didn't really realize
and I had all these people looking up to
me and also turning to me to have okay
hey my buddies in in trouble go talk to
Jody this guy's that she's in trouble
like and you're taking on all this other
stuff and honestly man self I don't know
what they call it self care I think is
what they call it self care is your
first priority
self aid we call it self yeah self aid
but that's like your first person you
got to take care and luckily my
daughters are so awesome that you know I
talked to them on the trip every day and
they okay when you get back yep well
we'll kick it off right where we left it
off but they're the first ones that are
gonna forgive you if you ask for it and
so I've asked my daughter's I told them
daddy's going through some stuff right
you noticed they're both like yeah
because kids don't get they don't give a
[__] echo you got kids right yes yeah
how many you got against you and they're
the first ones gonna tell you when you
they were the first ones that tell me
like hey how come you're not coming
around as much as you said you would god
damn it daddy's really busy yeah yeah
yeah you've always been busy we want to
go to the park but yeah man I'm on I'm
just trying to rebuild everything and
and stay stay on the path finally I
think I hope when I'm 50 I'm not going
through something again because by then
I'm just gonna be too old and want to
deal with [__] you know I'm like I'm not
saying that's old I'm just saying like
you should have your [__] together by
the time
50 I think or maybe I will but at least
I'll have these lessons learned over the
last since 2007 who said you're trying
to write these down you mean you're
writing down while you're going through
right now I'm writing it down and also
because I am in the position I am in
right you know we're we're authors now
out of anything else
like we talked we talked about this last
night doesn't make us artists but kind
of does write writing is an art but
people if people can learn from what I'm
going through and I know others have
written books and done the gone to the
exact same thing but we all have a
unique way of presenting things maybe I
turn it into a lesson
maybe I turn into something I read like
I've read your book four times since it
came out I'm rereading Tim Ferriss book
again 4-hour workweek because that's the
direction of life that I would like to
go in politics are not like doing it
your way but in a way that's smarter not
harder and in the Army right we learn
there's the part way there's the hard
way and then there's the army way or in
the Navy I'm sure it's the same and
sometimes none of them makes sense but
you get it done but I you know I want to
spend more time on myself my kids my
loved ones my friends and I think and I
sounds a little conceited and a little
bit egotistical and a little bit selfish
but I've realized that getting my legs
blown off maybe I've earned the right to
just do what kind of what I want a
little bit more than I did in the last
10 years and I want to hang out with my
friends do something constructive for
society still but if I want to go shoot
I want to go shoot if I want to drive my
car across America long I just want to
do that and I think I've earned the
right to have a little bit of
flexibility in life to just throw my
kids in the car and go well I actually
know you've earned that right and I told
you that the first day I met you
whenever when you were talking about
when you're doing and I was like man
you're you're doing way more than I'd be
doing you know I'd be I'd be spending a
lot of time my kids but you know you
have goals and aspirations and and
you've achieved those you know you've
done a great job up there and and so
that's good you know it's awesome to see
and if that changed directions and now
you can focus on you know taking care of
your family taking care of yourself
which yeah have you earned it hell yeah
you've earned it yeah well I think what
we always forget and what I forgot and
I've continuously have to remind myself
is I'm the beginning in the end of
everything in my world and that sounds
like a self what do you call it self
self-fulfilling prophecy no no self
involved a little too self-involved but
if I'm not up and ready to go at 8:00
a.m. my kids don't get to school in time
and if my kids are late their teachers
mad at them and then that's a snowball
in their life if I'm late
they wonder where I am if if I'm not at
the office my staff has to tell someone
hey where's counselor medic he's not
here right now where is he I don't know
or they may have to make him a [__]
excuse and even if you tell them your
job is to lie for your boss no no it's
not your job is be on to work on time
Jodie
so self-care and self-help and all that
stuff is and taking care of yourself is
the beginning of taking care of everyone
that you feel you have a duty to yeah
and that's ultimately what I want to
talk about here and what I want you know
so you know when I when I bust your
balls about getting up at 3:30 in the
morning that's what Jocko does to make
sure that everything in Jacko's life
falls into place for those you have four
kids bro yeah I don't know how you keep
up with them all I only have two and I
can barely do it and and so what I'm
saying when I go back to my having my
legs blown off earns me the right to be
a little bit selfish about what I do
with my time well I'm gonna be selfish
and take care of myself more which I
haven't for a decade well I would expand
that to really to everybody I'm gonna
tell you what I mean you owe it to
yourself everybody whether you've been
wounded or not right wherever you are in
life because the fact of what you just
said you got to remember this if you
don't take care of yourself you can't
take care of the other people around
right and and so you have to that's the
take care yourself you know my simple
thing and my wife knows this about me
like if I don't work out I'm I I'm not a
good I'm not I'm not the same person
right no good you know but but really if
I'm not taking care of my health then
everything else kind of starts falling
and so yeah you got to take care of
yourself and if you don't take care of
yourself then you can't take care of the
people that you care about and and so
that's the duty really and that's what I
wanted to talk about a little bit today
and what I was saying before about if
you're feeling it pull over and that's
the thing like you can't expect anything
of anyone else if you can't if if you
can't show up at work on time like why
should you your staff and if you don't
take care of yourself and then why
should you expect to take care of anyone
else and we all have support you know
and I'm at no I'm IO no I'm hammer in
this a little too hard but dude I'm I'm
learning a hard lesson here and I'm
trying to avoid we all I think have to
learn it but there's like there's you
can learn it harder than others and I
think I'm learning it the really hard
way because I am a public person like
like a private in Canada we call them
blog ins blog ins is like smithing in
the army so if blog ins is having a
rough time he doesn't have to go on the
radio and tell the world he doesn't have
to go on the jaakko podcast and tell the
world but he has to tell somebody and
that's the biggest thing you think you
think it's scary to go to a therapist
who is a trained professional like think
of a therapist like going to the rifle
range and learning from the master
sniper that's what you're doing you're
going to learn how to shoot and except
it's worth it for your mind would you
not go to the range to learn from a
master sniper if you want to be a better
shot of course you [__] would I will
I'm a master sniper and I'd go to the
range and learn from master sniper right
now that's what a therapist or
psychiatrist or psychologist or
counselor any of them are professionals
in the mental game of life now I'm not
saying all are equal as well if you
don't like one fire them and get a
different one but start there and start
looking for the help that's available
and don't put it all on yourself and
again if you think that's embarrassing
going to a stranger which is actually
pretty easy when you actually get in the
room and start talking you find you
might they might have tell you to shut
up because there's hours up try going on
the radio or the jaakko podcast or
writing a book like I you know I put out
a lot of my warts in that book too and
I'm still learning and I've got all
these resources so you know it's
it's not it's not you know one's too
proud no one's too tough and I'm about
done like talking because I was
something fun right now but no it's all
good man and I think you know I'm as we
were talking and I didn't I didn't know
if we were gonna do a podcast or not
when you came down here I don't know if
you want to talk about in this stuff
we're just gonna hang on I appreciate
this because the whole Drive I've been
thinking and talking to myself and
listening to other podcasts I'm like I
needed to do this yeah and really like
what you're saying is gonna it's
obviously it's gonna help people
especially the idea and I'm glad you
talked about this a little bit you kind
of threw it in there but like looking at
yourself in the mirror right looking at
yourself in the mirror and saying to
yourself you know what I need some fire
support here I'm gonna reach out I'm
gonna get it from some people yeah and
there's not a damn thing in the in the
world wrong with that and that's how you
sort of that was the thing that was the
thing that made you go okay
I need help I'm gonna go make this
happen and so it maybe that can help
some other people that aren't feeling
too good right now go look in the mirror
admit to yourself you got some problems
maybe the problems are a little bit
bigger than you we've been in combat
situations that were bigger than us you
have to call in fire support there's
nothing wrong with it there's no shame
in it go make it happen yeah and and
take care of yourself take ownership
extreme ownership I like the way you
think you know yeah I think that's a
good place man I think that's a good
place to chill if we want to talk about
something different we can do that
really easily all we do is we just ask
echo to talk for a little bit yeah get
in some some floss and stuff go Charles
yes you you know we want to talk about
something good can you talk about
something good like maybe how to support
ourselves and if someone wants maybe how
someone could support this podcast if
they want it's you should yeah chuckle
krill oil and joint warfare here's the
thing you know how like my joints I've
been hurting me lately yeah and
sometimes you can build it through some
germ warfare for sure yeah it helps not
in a non drug pharmaceutical way it's
good yeah it's interesting but it does
work especially if you're getting
physical and whatnot general joint
disintegration or D generation to
generation not dis not discretion yeah I
don't know how much you tell with this
integration nonetheless talk about some
supplements they're good supplements
their four-year joints one is krill oil
super krill oil the other one's called
joint where for glucosamine chondroitin
yes
curcumin and curcumin that's for like
cartilage it's all right it's Jerry more
no because you know like when your
meniscus or like your elbow stop saying
such big words just talk I'm telling you
this is this is the true the real deal
so if I take this the knee I tweaked the
other night this will help it with
discus around my kneecap yes
the the joint warfare well I'm into it
yeah fully also what we kinda talked
about earlier choco discipline
pre-workout we call it pre-workout but
it's a pre mission because that's
cognitive enhancers Judy's checking it
out write up about it nonetheless that's
good that's good for anything you're
about to do so we say pre-workout it can
be pre study
pre exam pretest pre-entry podcast
podcast whatever you like or whatever
you like it's good unless you can take
one or two scoops don't be a [__] take
two scoops guys like come on letter what
are we saying here sorry sorry I don't
know not at all I had a real long night
the other night of work and I took three
what do you normally to to so what do
you what are you weighing in now 220
no it's probably 230 230 and tow two
scoops is enough for you yeah yeah yeah
okay so I'll stick to two scoops for now
yeah but I might ramp it up to four if I
really have to be careful let make sure
you have something to do don't just take
like writing yeah that's right no that's
a great time yeah yeah and if you have
to write and then do you find it does it
make you jittery no no no I got smooth
but you got the energy yeah it's got
that means pretty low the caffeine is
very low
yeah the same caffeine is jockle white
tea it's the same amount so per scoop so
you'll get double that but it's not it's
a fifteen
so it's meant to not make you all
jittery because you can't that's not
good everything else I'm reading in here
and what little I do know about
nutrition this is all stuff for focus
and long-term like energy release yes
the only thing missing that I don't and
I don't know science is B vitamin is
that in there how am I missing it I
don't know so turning 40 means I have to
wear glasses now too by the way my
sniper vision I think is good for long
distance but now I'm like my dad you got
to find the sweet spot that's what it
over there right because your eyes can't
like el tercer whatever I'll be taking
can I have a case you can have that
right this right here actually that's
good and surprisingly tastes good you
didn't expect uncle to be like no I'm
very hyper about making things too
here's things taste like crap then
that's life is hard food should be tasty
yeah I dig it and I understand that but
you why'd you make chart you can drink
so you're saying it's out of character
for me too I'm in line I think that's
the dichotomy you heard that before even
like with how you sit you don't drink
coffee you're like I just don't like to
taste the coffee why would a tricky am i
all right you know right when I did
drink my friends you drink beer because
that's Canadian is to drink beer and I'm
like beer tastes like [__] I'll drink
cider oh the apple juice I'm like it's
got more alcohol in it than beer [__]
like it's what do you like if you didn't
like coffee he likes white tea I think
white tea sucks but I'm not Jocko we got
this I'm making this protein power right
now and like criteria number one was
yeah it has to be good protein and all
that but the strong second criteria was
it's got to taste so damn good yeah
which I forget you drinking protein the
first sample tasted really good like I
was shocked at how good the first supply
we tweaked it a little bit the second
sample came back it tastes even better I
mean we hang on how much sugar we
talking there's no sugar
oh no there's no that used to be the
trick this protein so good yeah but it's
no sugar and then the we've got one more
coming back but the second iteration of
it tastes delicious yeah and any samples
left no echoes yesterday he's like he's
like well you know I don't never really
like protein powder and I'm like bro
this is nothing to do with you wanting
to drink poking about her you'll be
drinking this like you want to drink up
there's gonna be like a chocolate milk
it's so good yes
yeah so we'll see about down on that one
it's working to get all this [__] echo
the proof is gonna be in the pudding as
they say for gin main dot-com that's
where you get it also at origin main
comm you can get you will get keys rash
guards is for jiu-jitsu by the way no
yes sir made in America
I know Jodie is from Canada better than
maiden somewhere else yeah Canada we
don't have time to make these and stuff
like yes I make it in America there's 10
times more people down here yeah I dig
it and all the stuff on there it's made
in America it's good good go there see
if you want something get something good
way to support also fitness gear Jaco
got a new kettlebell that is heavier
than mine is in his head is it or is it
is it your little head that you got on
this thing might as well be do my that
is the greatest if nothing else comes
from this from this is an avatar of you
if I want aqua proof I want like an
amulet of your head yeah shirt in the
back okay jong-kook done yeah it's good
yeah that kettlebell should be his head
cuz the reason he got it was because I
add a heavier kettlebell by happenstance
by the way I mean sorry is this a
kettlebell I can buy from jock oh no
this is just junk about it I was about
to say which it reminds me every time
I'm about to talk about kettlebells the
kettlebells I have you know the ones
from on it yeah I got all of them yeah
me too except I don't have the big foot
one tubers like that's a lot of eggs I
can't pick that one up is just too heavy
yeah prosthetics yeah no I dig it and I
haven't picked up anything for over year
anyway so that's what I was trying to
imply to Jocko that like since mine is
heavy I can pick it up he can't pick it
up etc it's two pounds everything's so
that's the way he got the heavier one
Roger that yeah I'm tracking now I'm
tracking more than six pounds
yeah congratulations
this was a custom-made kettlebell no got
it from rogue fitness rope right yeah my
boys at rogue fitness yeah but it's like
made in America it's like the boring
round one you know you can say yep I got
the ones yeah that's why I thought you
meant the Jocko was coming up with with
a kettlebell as well obviously it's
gonna be shaped like Jacko's hair should
that's my that's my because they could
do that and now I think a product was
just born
yeah maybe actually someone someone said
okay well anyway I agree agree it was
the longest commercial everybody it's
not a commercial you we deviated from
the koomer so Roger I'm sorry I'm sorry
no we're supposed to do that okay that's
part of the deal right I know I forgot I
told you I'm in basic training for life
again nonetheless back to the
kettlebells if you get kettlebells in a
way that's not competitive with your
friend or if it's competitive with your
friend whatever the ones from on it
that's the cool ones Jodie as a whole
set I have the whole set if you have the
whole set you're cool like us not like
Jocko also when you get Jody's new book
of course chocolates book any of the
books we read go or go over on the
podcast I made it easy for you got a
section on the website
yeah books for the website that I'm all
listed by episode by the way nice click
through there
get them through there real easy good
way to support as well they'll take your
Amazon just say sorry real quick
unflinching the making of a Canadian
sniper and everyday heroes yeah my two
books they'll both be on the website
yeah right be on your website everyone
yeah and they are available through
Amazon and what's the Kindle their
Kindle that's Amazon - yeah everywhere
right like audiobook yeah yeah yeah well
I'll have it all on the website so yeah
when you get that boom click through
there it's way easier for you
that's good way to support if you want
to continue shopping on Amazon to buy
your weed whackers and what else we'd
buy an Amazon go ahead do that - good
way also subscribe to the podcast if you
haven't already seems normal
seems obvious iTunes well if you want to
subscribe as far as subscribing those
it's more about like what you listen do
you listen to iTunes oh yeah that's what
it's exclusive exactly right some people
they listen to Google Play can you
subscribe on Google Play though oh yeah
okay that's what I was getting at I
don't know where else I get so sorry
it's the same thing yes after that and
there and now there's different apps now
yeah like they're basically I mean
really different at stop you're
confusing this is okay consider this way
and this is I'm new to this too okay
we're iTunes when you think podcasts
yeah I I pod podcasts so
podcasts are exclusive to iTunes it
feels that way where do you listen to
podcasts on iTunes obviously here's
think podcasts the podcast just cuz
iTunes has it's like if you wanna have
leave if I just went to the website with
your website again chocolate podcast
calm so if I go to Java podcast calm
could I listen straight from the podcast
for this story from the website yes on
my computer yes
Bob's your uncle boom there it is yeah
and yes I did not know yeah there's
basically all these different ways to
listen to it and in whatever way you
choose to listen to it there's where you
subscribe in the event of these things
offering the SUBSCRIBE option which I
think they all do I'm not sure because I
don't explore all of them it's just how
it works so what I'm saying is if you
want to subscribe subscribe good way to
support also on YouTube which we have a
YouTube channel by the way Judy mythic
Roger that
not just the video version of this
podcast but excerpts and various
creative videos here and there and some
outtakes by the way not many but you
know a few I'll put more up there also
chuckles door it's called chocolate or
chocolate or calm obviously that's where
we get or we make these shirts
Jody Seay this shirt chocolate is on
right now the victory MMA and fitness
yeah he always says that turn on by the
way he does that well not last night
that's why I was it was underneath my
flannel Roger yeah yeah how did you even
recognize that's why I wore my friends
so this is a tactical beaver shirt and
it's a Canadian company started by scan
soft guys dudes I was gonna wear this
last night yeah but I didn't I thought
jogging would show up in t-shirt so I
stayed in the t-shirt yeah yeah and
anyway so now he's in a t-shirt and I'm
a neurologist oh yeah man anyway I just
a tactical beaver was my last podcast if
you listen yeah they were on the show
it's good it's pretty
you know what else is dope the the shirt
jock was on and the shirt I have on with
chuckles hit on it and if you want this
shirt chuckles Norcom there's a lot of
shirts on their discipline I have a
green and black one in my suitcase back
in the hotel of that one I thought it'd
be weird wearing your shirt yeah I
thought so but there's a deeper meaning
I think the fact that Jacko's head is on
my shirt and I'm sitting now you're part
of the show so you gotta worry well
where do I should wear the echo shirt
sometimes there's an echo shirt there's
ninety five immediately yeah I have four
friends myself that want that shirt all
right there you go you got it sir man
I've been I've been out of luck since
May sorry and that's it you know what
and that's going back yeah I think plug
I don't want on Facebook while personal
I'm gonna keep the business side but
your personal stuff is good anyway you
can finish what you're doing I'm sorry
no you're part of what we're doing I'm
not gonna read a list of things that you
should or should not do I'm asking about
a message ah cool about it joggle tell
me a hurry up I may or may not hurry up
whatever that's how it works
nonetheless Jocko store.com any shirt
you want John I'm gonna go right after
the show yes this is also some patches
on there some hoodies rash guards hats
women's stuff on there kids stuff on
there it's good good babies a beanies
are on their way so if you go like well
you figure well beanies could very well
be on there they're on there you wear
beanies better taco when it's cold
outside when it's cold it's not a
fabulous naming for you okay here to win
then here to win no fashion no sure it
looks good though bro for sure anyway
chuckles store.com nothing go buy
something I'm not saying that be [__]
but if you like something get something
it's good way to support even also yeah
I don't know if you know about this you
might I don't know psychological warfare
is that ringing a bell I mean I know
what it is okay is this something yeah
so psychological warfare is an album
that we created with tracks choco truck
playlist yes a platelet playlist yeah I
prefer an outtake mixtape yeah yeah
mixtape of Joc was hurt
yeah essentially but here it's for
specifically right right right it's not
him playing the ukulele ukulele no
indeed it's him telling you how to get
through certain weak moments either his
his mom his videos no like no better
more specific so here here's what it is
okay good I'm actually glad you don't
you don't know that the specifics of it
because that way you can talk about it
for 28 minutes actually number one on
iTunes by the way but you know oh that
guy downloaded that I never listened to
it though sorry bro you don't need it I
just wanted to support my friend yeah
you give the support yeah that's right
but I shouldn't let it support you - I
probably that's really what it's for
yeah to support you I used to you know
how like you know when you worked out
and you don't feel like work you know or
you go to work out it you don't feel
like I felt like that for the last 18
months
I'll do it tomorrow I have been saying
that since last October all right with
you well they over 2016 ever saying that
I thought that was my biggest weakness I
come to jakka I said what are you doing
you don't feel like work you know I mean
I know cool your time what job do they
do I work out yeah but there's more to
it than that it's not that simple you
know and he explained it I said you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna record
that I'm always that that was the birth
of the psychological warfare I should I
did download it actually when it came
out I just I forgot I even had it look
at the tracks here's what you do look at
the tracks and be late cuz it's not just
missing work out it's like
procrastination I'm gonna throw at that
no yeah absolutely I got my black belt
in procrastination bro yes so consider
one that you're like okay not only will
it help
it'll 100% get you through it Roger that
it's been the case for me anyway get it
you can get that on itunes of course and
anywhere where they sell mp3's amazon
music what not too good on a couple
other things on amazon you can get jock
a white tee it's no big deal unless you
want to deadlift 8000 pounds minimum
then you drink Jocko white tea and
you're there no questions asked 100%
guaranteed you're freaking huh if you
want to get some books you can get Jody
midex books there's two of them
unflinching the making of a Canadian
sniper and also his latest book everyday
heroes which is war stories
from the generations edited by Jodi you
get way the warrior kid so you can teach
kids to do the right things in their
lives you know things like beyond the
path it's all I'm going to say this when
equals freedom Field Manual that book
yeah
it's about getting on the path and
staying on the path that's what it's
about not going to say anything else
about that one I will except for that
the audio version of that book is not on
audible it is on anywhere you can get an
mp3 which means iTunes Amazon music
Google Play and then of course the first
book extreme ownership combat leadership
there's a new version out it's black
which makes it a little bit cooler you
can get that learn how to lead also
beyond the books in the podcast if you
need leadership let's say leadership
guidance and direction at your company
at your business or at your team I have
a leadership and management consulting
company it's called a shell on phone and
that is what we do we come to your
organization we assess the situation and
we get problems solved through
leadership it's me it's my brother Lafe
babban that wrote extreme ownership with
me who was one of the platoon commanders
that served with me in the battle of
Ramadi it's JP Danelle who was the point
man and the lead sniper of Delta platoon
in the Battle of Ramadi it's Dave Burke
who was an f-18 Marine Corps fighter
pilot Top Gun pilot Top Gun instructor
Top Gun senior instructor f-16 pilot
f-18 pilot f-35 pilot f-22 pilot firsts
he sounds like he's pretty good at his
job he's not bad he's the first
operational squadron commander for the
f-35 he's the only man in the world
qualified to fly all those aircraft but
none of that matters because what he did
was cool was he was on the ground with
us in the battle of Vermont
as a anglich Oh team leader with his
team and was with what is an Anglican
it's it's the guys that call for fire
they like like you they attack yeah
their JTACs but the Marine Corps has
anglich oh but de couleurs go air naval
gunfire liaison roger that yoke and
that's what he did for us outstanding
guy he's been on the podcast number 16
number 69 I believe so he's part of the
echelon front team as well also on top
of that there's the muster it is the
leadership seminar with us
the echelon front team again in 2018
we're only doing two musters people
think we're going on as rock and roll
tour we're not going on a rock and roll
tour knock-on city to city is not gonna
happen in Cleveland it's not gonna
happen in Milwaukee it's not gonna come
to San Diego it's not gonna happen in
San Diego this year we're only going
place it's gonna happen in Washington DC
May 17th and 18th so that's where you go
if you're on the East Coast east of the
Mississippi you come to DC so they lived
what day
may 17th and 18th if you're west of the
Mississippi you come to San Francisco
October 17 eighth 17th and 18th that's
it like I said we're not going anywhere
else so the reason is because we don't
have time to do them it's to get all the
Echelon front team together and set it
all up it's very hard to do because
we're working with clients all over the
country and all over the world so we
can't just do musters all the time so
that's why we're doing two of them if
you want to come sign up all the four of
them we week that we've had so far have
all sold out these are going to sell out
to 100% so if you want to come you got
to go and register to attend extreme
ownership calm can I reserve two spots
right now and in Washington yes you can
all right cool cool cool yeah until then
until the muster if you have questions
or answers for us or you just want to
check in and share
your wins I noticed people do that now
on social media and share the winds yeah
it's good I got this promotion I
overcame this little situation they give
a little brief on a situation here had
this guy that was acting wrong I took
ownership and boom problem solved I lost
weight I gained weight
I got a stripe on my white belt in
jujitsu and I'm proud yeah
and I am proud yeah big time I'm stoked
when you get that stripe on the white
belt you know or the blue belt sometimes
people get the black belt the brown belt
but what we see is progression yeah like
I said people lose weight people gain
weight people stay clean people stay off
the sauce people stay off the drugs
people stay on the path and if you want
to check in with us about that stuff you
can do it on Twitter on Instagram and on
that bull Hachi baja Jody is at Jody
Minich
je o dee why am i t I see echo is at
Echo Charles and I am at Jaco Willick
echo any closing thoughts no thank you
for coming on and it's great to see you
again
do you do bro mr. Jody medic you got
anything else
jogo thank you for giving me the mic
back for five minute now I'm just
kidding uh I just want to say thanks to
you for bringing me on today I know you
did this because you didn't have to
because you wanted to and I appreciate
that and I needed this echo as always
you should stop drinking by the way I
mean now that I'm a reformed drinker
that's that's it that's the that's the
answer to everything
yes I get just stopped drinking
surprisingly it's a it's a big answer
it's a good you know if you look at that
study that comes out I forget who does
it I think it's the UN at the most
destructive force on earth is alcohol
above coke heroin speed crack it all put
together
booze is still ten times worse like that
like when it come because it's available
to everybody right I should thank
everybody that's been with me through
this you know sometimes you think you're
alone and you're not
I've had friends and family that have
not stopped basically you feel like
they're bugging you but they're not
they're keeping an eye on you and all
the supporters and the fans and and and
just the the the Jodie medic fans thank
you for being there for me thank you for
being honest with me
and thank you to my friends and my
family for putting up with me and I fell
off the path
I lost my bearing pretty bad but now
I've reorient ated the map and I'm back
on track and give me give me some time
the Jodie medic podcast will be back up
and running in short order give me six
weeks ish and we should have to be
pumping out some episodes who knows
maybe I'll fly Jocko up to Ottawa and
we'll do an episode I don't know the
point is something will be coming and
there's a few hardcore I'm talking
granite hard fans that have like stuck
it out and they send us at least a tweet
a week to be like where are you [__]
at and we're coming back quick
just real quick shout out to my friends
at tactical beaver if you want some of
their stuff just go on tactical beaver
yes like the animal you can get some of
their gear it's pretty cool Canadian
twist a Canadian flavor and if you're
you know if you're the one guy in your
unit that has it and you're not Canadian
you might be it might be popular for a
minute but and you know and the last
thing goes out to my kids
Ayla and Keira ale is nine peanut
curious six squeaky they're waiting for
me at home very patiently and what soon
as daddy's home we're gonna go to
jujitsu because daddy needs to learn to
and I know you guys don't like it now
but when you're older you will
appreciate it and for the rest of
everybody else we're gonna look in the
camera for a minute echo you're gonna
edit that in right sure I know I said
sorry before I'll say it again and I
thank you I will say over and over again
for supporting me and it's because of
people like Jocko and Rob who you'll
meet who's the green beret and some
other very special people in my life
that I am found a reason to get back to
being myself and and and that's about it
that's all I can say Thank You Man
awesome brother well it's awesome having
you back on again and you'll be coming
back on again and again as you continued
on this this journey actually I'll be
better and I Emily can just keep growing
down and helping others it's all good
well my next book comes out I will come
back that's awesome and so thanks for
coming on it's awesome to see you again
and like I said we'll keep doing this
for the next 20 years and finally thanks
to all the service men and women out
there right now right now think about
that right now right this moment in time
there's men and women out there on the
frontlines face-to-face with evil so
thanks to you all for protecting us and
our freedoms in to the police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
and the rest of the first responders
thanks for your service and your
sacrifice to keep us safe here at home
and to everyone that's out there
grinding working driving trucks pouring
concrete hammering on a project building
bridges or building software sewing some
garments or sewing of field farmers
factory workers engineers electricians
plumbers and pilots and ground crew and
cooks and waitresses to everyone out
there working hard and listening to this
and just trying to get yourself a little
bit better today than you were yesterday
thanks for listening and as you meet
struggles and as you struggle to stay on
the path first of all remember you don't
have to fight alone reach out to your
comrades in arms
[Music]
call for fire support when you need it
we win the wars because we stick
together and when we stick together we
can overcome any enemy and the struggles
that you face when they when they do try
to flank you do what Jodie did do what a
soldier does turn into the ambush turn
toward the enemy fire and attack until
next time this is Jodie medic and echo
and Jocko